Hey everybody, welcome to the podcast.
My guest today is Katie Hoff,
dubbed the female Michael Phelps.
For better or worse more on that in today's conversation.
Katie, made her first of two Olympic teams
at just 15 years of age.
And along the way, accrued three Olympic medals,
eight world championship titles,
a bunch of world and American records
and many other accolades.
But this isn't really some kind of unrelatable success story
because the thing about Katie,
what's most interesting about her to me at least,
is that this is an athlete that could
and probably should have had a far more decorated career.
So what happened?
Well today we get into all of it,
the high highs the crazy success at a young age
that led to insane pressure, expectations,
bitter disappointment of course,
all the valuable and applicable life lessons
learned along the way.
All of which you can also read about
in her recently released memoir Blueprint.
So do me a solid hit that subscribe button
if you haven't already.
And here we go, this is me and Katie Hoff.
So nice to meet you.
I know you too.
Thanks for coming out and doing this in person.
I know it's actually my first, I've never done a podcast
like this in person, person with like a studio.
That's so funny,
'cause it's all zoom these days.
All Zoom.
Yeah, but you've done a bunch of podcasts.
Just never, you've never done
an in-person podcast with anybody.
Maybe like, okay,
there was one that was like in a I wouldn't call it that.
(Katie laughs)
It's like in a in a small room and it wasn't like a studio,
but yeah I think over COVID,
I feel like I knocked out like 15
'cause it was just like all.
The book stuff.
Yeah,
I was the one having to worry about like my lighting
and like my background and I got really good at lighting.
(Katie laughs)
Well, we have good lighting here.
You have great lighting, I know.
You're gonna look fabulous on YouTube.
(Katie laughs)
It's all good, delighted to have you here.
It's so funny because of course I knew about your career
and followed your trajectory over the years.
But it wasn't until you started popping up
on Jesse Itzler's Instagram stories.
And I was like, why is Katie Hoff at Jesse's house,
teaching him how to swim?
I thought that was so entertaining.
And then you spoke at his like build your life resume thing.
And then I saw you at a book coming out and I was like,
oh she would be great for the show.
So that's when I reached out.
Well, thank you.
How did you get, how did you meet Jesse initially?
That's such a strange,
I mean he's such a funny, cool, awesome dude.
But I would not have predicted you two colliding.
Neither would I.
(Katie and Rich laughs)
It's actually a really kind of crazy jump connect story.
So I, Kurt (murmurs) who is a speech coach,
does his own speaking.
My agent at the time had connected us last year
to do like a speaking camp,
like cause you know I really love public speaking
and I knew I wanted to get into it more after my book.
And Kurt, had also worked with Jesse.
And I actually had known of Jesse before because Todd,
my husband had seen him speak at an Equinox Event.
And Todd was blown away by his charisma
and his energy and his story.
And so when I had the book coming out
I could just kind of got into this mode of like,
well I just wanna talk to every expert out there
that's doing what I wanna do
which is speaking and sharing your story.
So I just DM him, I just slid in the Dms of Jesse,
and I just said, hey, you know big fan.
You know, love, love what you represent.
I'm actually gonna have a book come out in a few months.
We have a mutual friend and Kurt,
what do you have, five minutes.
I just would love to pick your brain.
And I did this a couple of people
and Jesse responded within six hours.
Like, hey email me.
And I email him and we set up a thing.
We FaceTime which I was, oh my gosh.
And I find out that he's at his Connecticut place
has kind of got a house, and he's there for another day.
And he was like, "Look I'm gonna give you,
you know, your advice."
He was like, "But in return you have to promise to come
to one of my events."
That's the deal.
I was like, I don't see how this is a deal.
Like, these are all just benefiting.
Like how can I.
Right, they are all good for you.
Yeah, how can I, and I had heard him talk about
how he's doing you know this big,
fortunately got canceled this year
but big event with swimming.
And I'd seen that on his Instagram.
And I was like,
well why don't I give you a swim lesson in return?
And he was like, yeah, come out.
I was like, okay.
And you were in New York at the time, right.
So what'd, you just took the train
up and went to his house.
I just, we rented a car and I said,
do you mind if I bring you know my husband
and my little Frenchie?
And he was like, "Absolutely".
So we drove out and ended up spending the day
with his family and Sarah and gave him the swim lessons,
and just that's how it happened.
(Katie laughs)
He still blew that away.
I mean, first of all he's an incredibly gifted,
he is extremely charismatic,
incredibly gifted public speaker,
like so natural and moving.
Really like touched in that way.
But, but more than that, he just has this huge heart.
Like it's not surprising to me that he'd be like,
yeah come on over and hang out.
And he likes to have lots of people around,
you know like he's and he likes hiring young people.
Like there's all these young people
running around him and like working
on his social media with them and stuff like that.
And he's running this whole like enterprise,
you know basically off of his phone,
essentially you know.
Yeah, it's wild and you know,
Todd and I left and we were sat in the car
we drove away and I looked at him
and I was like I just feel like being around him,
you just wanna be a better person.
Like that's the best way to describe it.
Just how he and his wife interact,
and he interacts with his kids and it just was a very
cool experience to be able to meet someone so successful.
But he really is.
Incredibly grounded and always super enthusiastic
and optimistic, you know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just remember seeing video clips, he's in the pool
and he's wearing the Hoff cap.
Like he's wearing your swim cap,
and you know he's got a lot of work to do
on his swimming a little bit, you know.
But God bless him.
But I will I say the other day,
he posted a video in the ocean.
I was like, is that him?
Like, he looked so different
compared to what he looked like in the pool last year.
So I was impressed.
He was gonna do this ultra man race,
so I was helping him and my coach,
Chris health who also is friends with Jesse
was trying to guide him in the right direction.
But you know, he's doing a million different things.
Like his approach to these events is not the one that,
you know the hardcore athlete would take.
Like he's squeezing, I mean,
he gets all these workouts in
but he doesn't compromise any of the other things
that he's doing in his life.
Like, he's like, I just wanna finish you know.
He takes the training seriously
but he's not the guy who's like all in.
And like, this is what I'm doing.
Yeah, I feel like he's just like
whatever the race throws at me, I'm gonna handle it.
I'm just gonna tough it out and I've done it before.
So it sounds like that's what he did
for his a hundred miler.
Yeah, I know probably not the smartest though.
When he tells a story about how that went down.
Yeah, it sounds, it sounds crazy.
It sounds, I don't know how he did it.
It sounds like it just was mind over matter
type situation, so.
Well, here you are.
You're on the, the other side of,
you know incredible swimming career,
which we're gonna get into.
And now you've got this book and you did a Ted talk,
and you're kind of this, you know, public speaker person.
And you've got this business.
I'm always interested in the transition from
super elite athlete into, you know
the kind of pedestrian world of everybody else.
And it's not a very gracious one for most people
and it's very difficult.
And you seem like you're, you've had your, your bumps.
And I appreciate it in your book like how honest you were
about the difficulties with this.
Because I think it's really hard
when you're somebody like yourself,
who's so in the spotlight and everything is so excited
and the stakes are so high and everything that you're doing,
and all these people are paying attention.
And it feels like it's meaningful to then overnight be like,
"Oh, I guess I just have to figure out how to,
you know make my way in the world."
Yeah, and I think that's also why it took so long
to write the book.
People, I guess, five years isn't so long,
but to me it felt long.
And I never felt like I could be honest
about just how much I did struggle until this point.
And yeah, like you said it you go from, from the age of,
you know, I think even 10 new people were telling me
you know, you're Katie Hoff, like you're breaking state
records, that's who you are.
And I remember even telling my dad,
I think I talked about this in the book.
Like I got to queued in backstroke race
and I just had a meltdown and my dad was like,
"It's okay, like, it's fun."
I'm like, "No."
But like I can't, I've reached a level where like,
I can't do that.
I'm not supposed to mess up, I'm not supposed to fail.
And that carried all the way through.
And then to really end my career,
not the way that I wanted to.
And then I kind of took the other direction of,
instead of embracing everything that happened in my career,
I turned and ran and didn't want Olympian associated
with my name and said, I'm just gonna redefine myself
and be this corporate person and,
and be recognized and get accolades in that way, and.
Did you really go out of your way though
to make sure that people didn't know who you were,
like from the Olympic world in the corporate world?
Or did you, because most people would just trade off that.
You know, it's funny.
I think there were moments when I wanted people to know,
but at the same time, like it was, it was this,
I kept straddling this, this war with myself, you know.
I wanted to be recognized as,
that's what I've done with my life.
Because I like didn't make sense
if people didn't know that about me.
Like, wait, you're 26, you're starting this entry-level job.
Like why, so then I would want it to come out
and be like well, here's why.
Right, just so you know.
Yeah, just the, you know, like I'm not.
But I felt like I was starting over.
And so there's that side of it,
and then there was the other side of it where,
I didn't you know, I didn't like when I would get a call out
on a sales call for hitting great numbers
and they would be like the Olympian.
Because I wanted to be recognized
because I had done something.
Right, the merit on its own.
Yeah, so it was a weird straddle of pick the day
which day did I want people to know, did I not?
Yeah, I think it's a, there's this strange tension
with the athlete, not specifically swimmers
but people who are participating in sports
where it's it's really an individual thing
where you become, to reach the highest level.
You have to be very good at taking direction.
Like you have a coach and your coach tells you
to do these things and you execute on those.
So you're a good rule follower in that regard.
And hopefully under the best circumstances
that relationship with the coach is more of a partnership,
but it really is about kind of checking boxes right
and doing as you're told.
And yet at the same time, it's very,
so that bodes well for like the corporate world.
Like you have a boss and the boss tells
you to do these things and then you go out and you do it.
But on the other hand, your success is dictated by
basically it's between you and you, right.
And, and you're fueled by this desire
to be the best version of yourself, right.
Yes.
And that's kind of an entrepreneurial sort of flare.
So those two things kind of work together,
I think in the sport of swimming.
But when you go out into the world,
you kind of have to decide
like am I gonna be in the corporate machine,
or am I gonna try to do my own thing.
And I, and your book, I see that tension playing out.
Like you're trying both things and trying to figure it out.
Yeah, it's funny.
And I feel like I'd always claimed to everyone that,
oh I could never be an entrepreneur
because I didn't see this side of it.
I just saw, yeah.
I'm the most successful version of myself,
when I'm being told what to do.
I check the boxes, boom, boom, boom success.
I never thought that I had that in me
and that entrepreneurial spirit,
which now I know that I do.
But I think that's why I immediately be lined to
the corporate world,
because I saw the parallels I saw, okay.
I hit this number of emails and this number of calls
and you know this number of activity that equals
being this on the ranking of success.
And it correlated, it was almost an easy transition
but it wasn't healthy one because it just,
I also, you know when your check, check, check the boxes
and swimming, you're, you're trying to break a world record.
You're trying to get the best
in the world.
Yeah, there's a much greater
personal investment in what that success looks like
than there is in the corporate world.
Yes, and so I think after a few months,
I was wondering why I was, I had this empty feeling
because I was doing what I thought I was supposed to do.
Like, okay, well this worked with swimming,
you know check the boxes, I'm doing everything possible.
I'm going above and beyond, I'm staying late,
I'm coming in early.
Why do I not feel dissatisfied again,
like I thought it was that easy to be like
swimming's done, great.
I'm just gonna transfer all of those skills I learned
and go into the corporate world and
it's gonna easy.
It's gonna be awesome.
So there were, I mean, there were definitely a lot of things
that translated really well, just ins to me.
Sales and swimming you know, there's a scoreboard,
there's the you know, getting to know people,
understanding them, matching, mirroring.
Like I loved, I love that piece of it where I could
have and I was in the fitness world.
So I could have someone in front of me learn about them
and and help them, you know, find a fitness journey.
And I was very passionate about that.
But the hard part was when I hit the numbers,
I didn't have that same feeling.
It's not like getting on top of the podium.
(Rich laughs)
It's not, but I felt, I felt very I think misunderstood
because again, the world I had plunked myself
out of the swimming world where I was surrounded
by individuals who were going for those same goals as I was.
You know being fortunate enough to be
in a really high level club, to high-level
you know swim teams where others were going
for the Olympics.
And so to be surrounded by people who
hadn't had those experiences.
I felt almost like, wait, why do I not feel this way.
Because they're telling me I should feel this way.
And I felt very, like, what's wrong with me, kind of.
And maybe I'm just not being patient enough
and look how long it took me to become an Olympian.
It took me 15 years from the time it's not even 10 years,
from the time I started swimming.
So maybe it's just that I'm not being patient enough.
And I was beating myself up over that and thinking,
okay, well I just, I just have to wait
and then I'll feel satisfied.
But then at some point you realize not for me.
Yeah, I think at some point I had to hit myself,
hit myself over the head with it enough times to realize,
no I don't think that I don't,
it's not that this organization
or that organization isn't great.
And I'm learning things but I don't think that,
I think I need to do something that I'm owning
and I'm able to set the rules
and I'm able to feel empowered to do so.
And that took five years before I even had the confidence
to say that.
Yeah, well, at the same time,
you don't have a coach either, right?
Yeah.
You have Todd and you have support
but it is a little bit of a different thing.
It's scary in that regard.
But the difference is you now then have
that personal investment in your success.
It's like where you take it,
correlates to what you decide to do
and the work that you've put in.
Which makes it kind of like swimming, right?
Yeah, yeah and I think for the longest time
I kept thinking, okay 'cause my whole thing was
okay, what did swimming give me,
why did I like swimming so much?
And it wasn't necessarily the actual sport.
It was what it made me feel,
and that feeling is extraordinary.
I felt extraordinary to be striving
to be the best in the world.
That was such an awesome feeling to me.
And for the longest time I was like,
well maybe I'm just never gonna get that feeling again.
Maybe those are the glory days
and maybe I'm just not going to, but it was more,
no you just need to find a passion again
that is equal or greater than what swimming gave you.
And it wasn't, you know, fitness sales,
it wasn't operations.
It was being able to share my story and then,
you know empower others to also feel strong and confident.
And that's, I think how it finally all clipped.
Yeah, well, you're lucky that it,
that it has clicked so soon for you.
It took me a lot longer, you know what I mean?
I think, I think, you know we put
so much pressure on ourselves,
especially in this kind of Instagram culture
that we all live in.
Like you have your passion and you know,
you need to quit your job and like do your thing.
And now's the time, and I think that ends up
making a lot of people feel bad about themselves.
We have lost our ability to just value.
Like it's cool to have a nine to five job
that where you can pay your bills
and you know, put food on the table.
And if that's providing you with,
you know value in your life, like that's fantastic.
But for some reason we've decided
that's not good enough.
And I think it puts undue pressure,
especially on young people
to have things figured out right away.
Like either right out of high school or college,
and these things take time.
Like there's a process of,
you know you have to go on this inside journey
with yourself to discover what that is.
And for some people they figure that out quickly.
Like if you had been rather than a swimmer,
a guitar player or you know a violinist
or something like that that's something that you could apply
for the rest of your life.
But because it's sport, it has an expiration date on it.
And when you're trying to compete at the highest level
there's no mental space to consider
what you're gonna be doing next.
And I think that creates an existential crisis
for a lot of athletes.
For sure, yeah and it's almost like if you,
if you, in my mind if I was planning for my future,
that mean, that meant I didn't believe in what was
happening in a year.
Right.
Like, wait, why am I, the Olympics are in a year?
Why would I plan on what's happening after?
Right, you're jinxing yourself.
Totally.
You can't, you can't
make plans for what comes after
because that means that you don't believe
that you're gonna be able to do the thing
that you're working so hard to achieve.
Yeah, and I remember always had this canned answer.
It was when I was living in California
and I thought I was gonna go into the fashion world.
I thought I was gonna,
yeah that was gonna be what I was gonna do.
And people would always ask like,
you know, so what's gonna be next.
And I remember thinking what's next,
like and I'd be like yeah, like I think I'm gonna
go to fashion school.
Like that was just like my brush off answer.
But you know, when you're all in, you're all in.
Like there's no, for me, at least.
And maybe that would have provided a little more
balanced had I had a hobby or I was looking ahead,
but I think just naturally,
like that is just my personality on the obsessive side.
And that's, it's a strength as well as a curse
but I was not looking ahead.
It was just let me focus on making this next team and,
and that's all I care about.
Yeah, I think that's, that's most people in your situation
and that's the way.
I mean, yeah you can, there is no space for that.
Like when you're trying, when you're talking
about not just tenths of a second, but hundreds of a second,
you have to be so all in that you can't devote one second
to considering what's gonna come after this chapter.
Yeah, and I would think I mean,
any one, like, you know anyone who's successful in business,
in entrepreneurship, in a sport, I feel,
I feel like that is a trait where you can hyper-focus
and be I say obsessed, but consumed in the best way.
And that's how you reach that top level.
Right.
And so I actually, I love that feeling.
I love being all in on something
and just gripping it and not letting go
until it's everything has been squeezed out or it's done so.
Right, which is why it's not surprising
that you were magnetized by Jesse and Sarah.
Yeah.
'Cause they're both all in
on what they do in the way that they live their lives.
Yes, to the extreme, I think it's, yeah.
Jesse, especially with, with some of the things
he does like he, even the way that he does,
you know the steam room or the other cold tub,
like that is all like every thing that he does,
I would say is 150%.
Because how you do anything
is how you do everything,
right,
Yeah, exactly.
Well, let's take it back.
I mean, what what's so compelling about your, your career.
Isn't so much the great successes that you've had.
It's, you know, for me, at least what
what resonates is the disappointment.
Like on paper yours is a career
that probably should have been a lot more decorated
than it was, right.
And so you've had to kind of manage expectations
and pressure over the years
as somebody who showed such extraordinary promise
as a young person.
And lived up to and fulfill some of those expectations.
And yet at the same time, I imagine you know,
you're in a position where you have to look back
and reflect on that career and deal with the fact
like that you you probably could have done things
that you didn't do, right.
Is that fair?
That's very fair.
It's a very hard pill to swallow.
And I think again, why I took so long to write the book
I just wasn't, I wasn't ready to swallow the pill.
Like it was just way too big and.
Because what, it's talk to me about that.
Like just the fear of,
of reckoning with that, like emotionally.
Yeah, I think, and every time I think every time
I tried to, it was just breakdown.
You know, and fortunately I have a partner
and a husband now who is very understanding of that.
But I would get triggered all the time
by watching swimming or, you know
remembering a memory or just.
If someone doubted my effort,
there was just so many things that were coming up
and I kept just saying, okay, the past, in the past,
I just need to move on.
And which we all know like is the worst thing
you can possibly do.
But I think I just had such sadness
over certain parts of my career.
And I didn't really know,
it's hard to, it's hard to say to someone
who doesn't quite fully understand.
I have three Olympic medals and I'm disappointed by that.
Right.
And I didn't, I didn't feel comfortable saying that
really until I said it in my Ted talk, which was 2018.
That was the first time I wrote it.
And I was like, am I gonna say this out loud to people
and what are they gonna say, and are they going to judge me?
But that's the ultimate opener doing a Ted talk.
I have three Olympic medals and I'm disappointed.
Welcome to my Ted Talk.
(Katie and Rich laughs)
I actually started like that.
I was quite confident to own it quite like that.
But yeah, I think really the only
and I said it to my husband, or the first time I met him.
Like the first night we had a conversation,
I admitted I felt comfortable to.
You know he was an elite athlete too,
and I felt comfortable to say that,
but yeah I just felt like it was,
I would burst into tears and I wouldn't know why.
And whether I would be at work in the bathroom
and I would just start crying.
Our office had clear windows
which was terrible for that type of thing.
But yeah, I think it was just,
I appreciated people in my life for not
kind of forcing me into that,
and just kind of letting me kind of flail for a few years.
I almost think that was necessary evil part of the healing,
but yeah, I just.
Even now and I think I write this in the book,
like it's never, I'm never gonna look back
on certain things and be like, yeah, I'm okay with that.
Right.
There's just, and I think that's most people
like there's certain parts or certain things
that might happen in your life,
where it's just going to still be a little painful.
And I think that's just okay,
you just have to learn from it.
Well, Caroline Burckle, who was just here,
who you lived with when you lived in California.
You guys were roommates.
How long did you live with Caroline?
We lived together for almost two years.
And then I was still living
'cause I was in a city of Orange.
So Newport City, and then
she was still living in Santa Monica.
So I would drive up all the time.
Right.
But she was talking about the traffic today.
I was like, oh I remember
when I got up on Saturday afternoon to visit you.
Yeah, but Caroline, who's been on the show
a couple of times, Big Podcast favorite.
She talks about being this kind of feeling athlete
like for her, it's all about emotions and how she feels.
And the sense that I get from you
is that you're quite the opposite.
Like you're like, here's the set that I'm doing.
And here are the numbers that I have to hit.
And here's where my heart rate has to be.
And here's how many hours of sleep I have to get.
And your confidence is derived from,
from, you know checking those boxes
like we talked about before, right.
Like as long as I do these things
that I can stand up on the blocks and feel confident about
my ability to execute in this race.
You're, you're an and I guess with that comes a sort
of detachment from that emotional self that,
that is kind of Caroline's fuel.
And reckoning with, you know,
the kind of wake of your career is requiring you
to be a little bit more like Caroline, right.
And like wrestle with some uncomfortable emotions
because you can't be, like that robotic approach
served you well in some regard as an athlete,
but as a human being, it it truncates your ability
to kind of mature and work through all of that.
Yeah, that's such a great point.
I've actually never thought of it like that.
But yeah, it's actually funny when Caroline,
and I lived together we'd be having conversations about sets
or it was like we were speaking two different languages.
She doesn't even know what the qualifying times
are anything.
She's like "What were my
pieces at times." I'm like, I'm like 27.1, five and 20.
You know, so I was, and I think that,
you know that started very young at 13, 14.
I actually never forget when,
so Eddie Reese Olympic coach just retired.
And he's one of the first people I remember
going to an Olympic camp, pre Olympic camp.
And he was like, all right we're gonna do
these 100 yard swims.
And they're just strong,
and that was like a nightmare.
Like what,
what does that mean.
Like strong,
can you be more specific, like to the hundred
that he was like, "You're 13 years old, just go."
You know, but that was just never how I operated.
Like I had a whiteboard in my house
with covered in times like down to the hundredth.
And that is, I think from a very young age
where I derived all my confidence from.
And so you're right, when there were no splits,
there were no, there was no specific,
here's the order that you do things.
Here's how you go about this in a very structured way,
I felt like I was in a free fall.
And not knowing not having had the tools to really
handle the emotion because even after 2008,
I didn't really handle how Beijing went.
No, you just move forward.
Just move forward.
Right, compact metalize.
Yeah, and wonder why those four years were probably
one of the toughest times of my life,
because it just everything everything's just shoved down.
And okay, like what times do I need to go now,
and how much cardio do I need to do?
And all those things that I just clung to.
So that's why I look at all of this as this,
you know obviously I'm sure you would have liked your career
to have gone differently.
But it does like what occurred
provides you with this amazing growth opportunity
to kind of look at yourself in a way that maybe
had everything gone the way that you wanted it to,
you would never really do
because you wouldn't be compelled to, right.
For sure, so ultimately you can become
this more self-actualized individual by really,
you know, not not trying to deny it or look away from it
but actually going towards it.
Yeah, and I think that's what I eventually
came to and what really helped me move forward.
And, you know, I have solved my days.
But I think, like you said, self actualized
understanding what I went through,
understanding the struggle and really being able to talk to
you know, young individuals entrepreneurs, right.
That if I just had one, gone and won five gold medals,
win, win, win, I probably would never
have taken a look inside and understood.
Okay, what do you how do you hit rock bottom,
seemingly your rock bottom and get back up
and what do you do and how do you fight,
and all of those things that I think now
I can speak to someone on a very vulnerable
and authentic level and connect with them.
Because people experience that all the time.
Yeah, it does makes you much more accessible and relatable
I think in that regard, but I also look at it,
I'm somebody who's been in recovery for a long time.
And, and the way I kind of look at addiction
or any kind of like errant behavior
where you're living out of alignment
with a better version of yourself is that
the universe begins to knock gently and says,
hey, maybe you should take a look at this thing
that you're pretending doesn't exist.
Yeah.
And you ignore it and you ignore it.
And you're like, I'm gonna buckle down.
I'm just gonna keep doing it my way.
And you can get a certain level of success with that
but then it'll knock again, be like,
hey, yeah I'm still here.
You're still not looking over here.
You know what I mean?
Until eventually that knock becomes undeniable
or your whole life falls apart, and you're just forced to.
And you know, I've had that with substance
but when I look at your career, I'm like,
oh, you know there were certain things that kind of happened
along the way where maybe you could have,
you know course corrected a little bit, but it's like,
no I'm gonna keep doing it my way.
And then it's like, okay, that's not working out.
Now it's, you know, you know,
it's, it's a stomach issue, right.
At some meat you had and then and then the blood clot thing,
and it's like, it had to actually get completely
pulled out from underneath you in order for you
to kind of like deal.
Yeah, I know the 2012 trials,
like just I've never had a worst stomach feeling, never
never been able to not eat.
Like I remember people were like, you're just nervous.
I'm like, no, this is my third Olympic trials.
I'm not nervous, I just, I feel so ill.
And now looking back that's the one thing I'm like,
why like why, like, I didn't feel like.
I thought I could swim through it
and it it didn't make a lot of sense.
And, you know ended up not making the team because of that.
And then at that point that was probably
in the thick of me flailing.
I just had not dealt with so many things
after 2008 and had no idea who I was in terms of identity.
And then, you know make a comeback finally feel like
I had made strides.
I think I had had been a better partner in a,
you know coaching athlete relationship.
I had empowered myself a lot more.
I was in a really healthy relationship.
And then yeah, blood clot thing happens.
(Katie laughs)
Yeah, still need to,
still need to know.
You're like half way there, so.
Right.
(air whooshing)
We'll be back in a sec, but first
if you dig this podcast and I hope you dig this podcast,
then I think you'll really
enjoy my latest book, Voicing Change.
Featuring excerpts from Poignant essays,
by and glorious photography of some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight plus years of doing this thing.
This podcast it's a gorgeous artful compendium of the show
and copious wisdom shared there in all wrapped
in a hardcover coffee table form that provides a great taste
of what we do here at the RRP.
And serves as a beautiful keepsake or gift
for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website.
Signed copies are available, and we are shipping globally
direct to any coffee table on planet earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit rich roll.com/vc.
That's rich roll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
(air whooshing)
Well, for people that aren't familiar with your career
we should probably walk through it a little bit.
So they understand what we're talking about
but I wanna go back to the beginning.
So you, first of all, your parents met at Stanford, right.
Yeah.
And your mom was like this high point basketball player,
high points scoring to this day, right.
Yeah.
Like she was a crazy star
on the Stanford women's basketball team.
Yeah, she was a beast.
It was cool in 04' when you know Palo Alto
is where the campus held for the Olympics.
I was able to actually go and see her name on the list.
And at that time it, she was third time
all point score at the time.
Like Arrillaga, the alumni center
where they have all the sports stuff.
Yeah, it's actually a funny story.
When my mom got that that point total
that got her on the list, my dad decided to run onto
the court with flowers in the middle of the game
to give her.
Wow, oh my God.
If you knew my dad,
you would not, it's very out of character for him.
And my mom was happy
but also like the clock is still running.
Like what are you doing?
There has to be video of that.
I don't think there is, I've asked many times.
Like that was in the day where, I mean,
now we'd have it on the cell phone.
Yeah, now we would for sure.
I would, I'd be surprised what year,
so wait what years were your parents at Stanford?
So my mom, she would have been 78 to 82.
Okay.
And my dad actually, he went to Purdue
but he did his master's at Stanford.
And they actually met they were both,
which my mom's coach was not happy
about this after the fact, but they both did
not bungee jumping, but they jumped out of a plane
and did the whole free-fall thing.
And my dad came down and landed on his ankle
twisted his ankle and mom went so cute.
My mom went and you know, stayed with them in the hospital
for the day, and that's how they met.
Oh, that's cute.
I was just thinking like,
if there was video of him running out with the flowers
you could edit the video of how.
Todd, running out?
(Katie and Rich laughs)
Exactly.
Todd, running out proposing to me.
Yeah, I know.
I feel like I need to try to do more digging
because that would be really cool.
That's actually crazy, I've never thought of it like that.
They both ran out.
Yeah, so I showed up at Stanford in 85'
so I just missed them.
Okay.
But that's how close I am to your parents' age,
which is embarrassing.
(Katie and Rich laughs)
But then what's interesting is you're homeschooled.
So you're born in Palo Alto, right.
And then you're homeschooled all the way
through high school.
Pretty much, there was a period of time in kindergarten
and fourth grade where I demanded to go to school
because I just wanted to see what it was all about.
And I was like, okay, well, that's fine.
And what was, what was that about for your parents?
It started that when,
you know when I was gonna be going in middle school
first grade, second grade, the school system wasn't great.
And so my mom kind of begrudgingly was like,
"Okay, you can go,
but I don't feel great about this school system."
Were you living in Maryland already at that time?
No, we were in Virginia.
So we moved from Palo Alto to Virginia, when I was five.
Right.
And yeah, it just kind of was something
that my mom was gonna homeschool my brother and I.
And then it kind of morphed into,
well this is actually working out really nice with swimming.
My schedule, it's not as stressful.
And my brother ended up going
to middle school and public school.
And then he was in public school throughout that time.
But I liked it, I felt like I got my social
from my swim group.
I still got to go to homecoming and prom with friends.
And so for me, it was just like I watched these kids
so stressed not getting enough sleep.
And I was like, I don't want to do that.
So I'm just gonna say homeschooled.
So where does swimming enter the picture, pretty young?
Young, but entered at five, but like summer league.
Right.
It lasted a year because I was the tiniest little kid
and I was freezing all the time and I told my mom I'm done.
So did summer when I was six.
Which summer league pool did you swim for?
I swam at the Kingspoint Dolphins
in Williamsburg, Virginia.
Yeah, okay so you're further south,
'cause I grew up in Bethesda.
So I know that whole, what is it MCSO
like summer league circuit of all the summer pools.
It's big there.
Yeah, it's a big deal, like very competitive.
Yeah, like it was, I mean, that's every,
it was everything and parents were intense about it
and kids were intense about it.
But I just kinda hadn't found like I wasn't,
I was definitely neurotic little kid,
like literally from like an arm was out of place
in my doll lineup.
Like I would have a meltdown, so it was very,
(Katie laughs)
I was excessive compulsive, but I wasn't.
Which is, goes in hand in hand
with the whole splits and being
like very controlling about the whole thing.
It all, it all lines up.
Actually heard that story for the first time from my dad
like three weeks ago, I was like, really.
I did that, he's like, yeah, like it was a thing.
It was a thing, wow.
And then, so then I kinda missed it
and had friends doing it.
And seven is when I went to the year round
where it was still twice a week.
Right, but still that's, that's pretty young
for year round to get into the year round thing.
Definitely, yeah and at that point
I still wasn't getting it.
Like I was not.
Still, it's so interesting to say still,
you're freaking seven years old.
At that point I'll take,
at that point I wasn't, you know, I was,
I was cheating like, which I hate telling this
'cause it just hurts me to my core.
But my like the coach would, we'd be doing walking lunges
around the pool and the coach would turn her head
and I would do like a little mini run
or we'd be in the middle of like a 50 meter pool
trying to swim.
And my mom would say I would stop and turn around
but there's no one behind me to like, get a break.
Right, so you're the kind of person who looks
at that and thinks if I hadn't done,
if I had cheated when I was seven,
maybe it would've been different.
Not that extreme
(Katie laughs)
I just cringed at it because I just,
you know, I hate that.
But and then I kind of had this moment where my friends
obviously they were beating me,
but I remember thinking like,
wait, like I don't know when it clicked
but it was just like, wait, like they're beating me.
And this is a race, and I don't, I don't like that.
And I think that was around probably eight,
just turned nine and it was a very big shift.
Like it was suddenly like,
okay, like how do I how do I now, how do I win?
This is unacceptable.
How do I, how do I become the best, how do I beat them?
And that's when I talk about this moment a ton,
as I had this moment in practice where I kind of figured out
how to reach this extra, I called deep down gear.
And at 10 you decide I'm going to the Olympics.
Yeah, yeah 'cause that nine I made,
like I mean the progress was crazy.
Like I decide, okay, I'm gonna start,
I wanna start beating people.
I learned how to kind of work hard and reach
that uncomfortable level of pain and practice
At nine at night.
At nine, (Katie laughs) didn't know what that was yet.
But told my dad I found the deep down gear.
and just like, okay.
I feel like so many times our parents probably looked
at me like, who is this child?
Right, it's almost like a weird past life thing, right.
Like how are you at nine to have the self-awareness like,
oh I have to really push myself.
You know, that's, it's almost like your brain's
not even mature enough to understand that equation.
No, well, especially that, you know
I work with young, young, young kids and I don't,
I didn't think it was weird until I started working
with people and not hearing that a lot.
And I'm like, oh, that was kind of unique.
Or I won't say weird, but a little strange
that I was that conscious of that
and that conscious of even what pain is
and pushing past pain.
But there were, I mean the results were so immediately
happening for me, which was I think lucky in some ways,
like I did the work and then suddenly it was like,
oh, I just, now I'm talked to in the state
and now I'm breaking state records.
And the momentum just kind of flows.
Right, so at 10, what was the epiphany
in terms of the Olympics?
Like, was there something on television
or was there somebody you were looking up to
that, like that light bulb went off?
2000, I had just turned 11.
And that was when I remember us we were on vacation
at the beach and we had the Olympics on.
And I remember Kaitlin Sandeno was 17,
and she was swimming 400 IM.
And she was, I think she, she meddled in a couple of events
and I was like wow, like, how cool is she.
She has this cap, you know, USA cap with her name on it.
Like I just was enamored by the whole thing
and not having any idea of how do you make an Olympic team?
You know, how how'd she get there, what did she do?
I just was like, oh, I need to do that.
Yeah.
And of course I think, you know every, every kid
at that age says like, I want to be an Olympian, you know?
And so I remember always being.
I don't think they do though?
You don't think so?
No, I don't think so.
I think a lot of kids are just having fun
or the parents are like you need to get out of the house.
And not like, all right.
What's what's the time you gotta make it.
Yeah, I guess maybe a little older, but I think
I was saying it with like intent, like I was saying like
okay, like, all right, so what's the next cut?
What's the trials cut, you know what I need to do, and.
A tenure, like what's the trials cut.
(Katie and Rich laughs)
Your parents must have been like,
"What is going on with these kid?"
They definitely had to hold me back a little bit,
because I remember at 11 I was angry
as all get out because the older kids
were doing doubles two a days.
And I was like, well, I need to be doing two a days.
Like how can I be doing two a day?
And they were like, you have plenty of time in your life
to be doing doubles.
And so they held me back a little bit, but I mean,
was pretty hard once I was released, I was locked in.
And yeah, I remember I made my first nationals at 12 and.
That's crazy.
Yeah, and just I mean, I didn't swim well, but I.
You must have been the youngest person by a long shot.
Yeah, I think,
yeah I think at that national, is that the only reason.
You see young like, like boys don't end up qualifying
for nationals until like the very early, like 16
maybe a 15 year old women, it tends to happen
a little bit younger.
There's the occasional 13 year old
but I've never heard of a 12 year old making nationals.
I think the only other, and there's been,
yeah it's like very spotty throughout the years.
You know, Dana Vollmer.
I remember she was at trials at 12 or something like that,
but yeah, it was, again it was rare,
but in that instance, I just didn't.
You were like, of course.
I'm like this is normal and it was kind of good.
I think, to be honest that I didn't,
I didn't feel no one made me feel like I was abnormal
or if they did, if they were like what's,
I found, I felt special.
You know, I felt excited.
Like, wow, you know, it must I must be doing something
pretty cool here.
And I remember the boys that I swam with
'cause I saw him at 15, 16 year old boys.
And boys I say they were definitely not men,
boys were jealous or you know,
and that may maybe even more like,
"Oh, like I'm just gonna be competitive about this."
But at that me in 2002 I watched Natalie Coughlin
break the world record in the a hundred backstroke,
and go under a minute for the first time.
And I remember that even more.
So I was like, oh, like Olympics, but like,
now there's a world record on the table.
Like that just kind of upped the ante for me in terms of
really lighting the fire of, okay.
I need to do all of these things now, how do I do it.
Yeah, and at 15 you materialize all of this.
You make your first Olympic team in 2004.
Yeah, which I even a year out I did not expect that,
you know, I obviously had the goal to make an Olympic team,
but I remember sitting down a year out.
My parents, we moved to Baltimore.
Yeah, a year out from 2004.
Was that specifically to join NBAC
or your dad got a job or how did that work?
Half and half.
Yeah.
Half and half,
at that time I was doing well on my team in Virginia,
but it was it was tough because again,
I was swimming with boys and I didn't really
have any female training partners
and I just felt like we needed something more.
And at the time too my dad was commuting
to Maryland anyways.
So we were like, let's give it a shot.
And I clicked really well with with Paul Yetter
who, you know gave me exactly what my robot self wanted
in terms of times.
And I remember we drove up there for
like a kind of a trial practice on a Saturday morning.
And we were doing a set of two hundreds,
and he showed me the piece of paper
and it was literal splits for each 200 and my eyes lit up.
Was like, this is my guy.
I have like, we are moving.
You got me, I'm sold so.
Yeah, what was interesting about
about reading about that in your book,
was that, I guess I just assumed that if you're swimming
at NBA, see you're swimming
for Bob Bowman and there's that one pool, right.
And I didn't realize that it was more like
the team that I swam for curl where there's multiple pools
around the region and there's lots of different coaches
and you were swimming in this
really shitty tiny little pool,
like four lanes and like, yeah.
It was called Night Divers.
So yeah, there was like.
It was like a scuba diving tank or something?
Pretty much it had this bubble over it.
And the, I mean the, I was coughing every night.
Like it was, you didn't roll up to this place
with this bubble and think an Olympian
is gonna come from this pool.
Right.
It was hot, but yeah, it was a group of 10 or 12 of us
and the, the girl Courtney Kailash
her brother chase is actually an Olympian now.
We had met at a regional meet and hit it off really well.
And you know, she was swimming really fast
and I I felt like, okay, great.
Like I can have a female training partner.
And so that was kind of the draw as well as Paul was having,
you know, a girl that I could I could connect with
and train with.
And we became really good friends.
So you go to trials, you qualify in two events,
200 IM and 400 IM, right.
You're only 15 years old.
That had to be, you know.
Surreal.
Yeah, very surreal.
And then you're faced with the prospect
of actually having to do it at the Olympics.
I think people don't understand
like it's all about trials, right.
Like your, your perspective doesn't really extend
beyond that because it's all about making the Olympic team.
Then you make it, then you're like,
oh shit, I've got to actually go
to the Olympics now and swim.
But you were so young, I can't imagine
that there was a huge amount of expectation
and pressure on you to like metal or win gold.
You know, like win gold or anything like that,
maybe on yourself, but externally.
I feel like I'm, I'm very thankful that social media
wasn't as big back then what 17 years ago.
But I remember reading articles and,
you know the day after Charles was done,
I was with this group of Tom Malchow
and Kaitlin Sandeno who I just watched four years earlier
to be in this big sports illustrated thing.
So there was that, there was all of these,
there was articles about meddling.
So I felt like, at least at the time it felt like,
okay, like now you're expected to win medals
for the US and maybe win gold.
And, but you're so right.
I was, so, the year out I was obsessed with just making
top eight, that's all I wanted to do.
I was like, you need to make top eight.
So that in 2008, I'm prepared with the experience.
Once again, like very I'm prepared for the experience
of swimming and Olympic trials final, and then,
you know drop a ton of time.
I win both events.
And then yeah, it was like, oh my God, that means
I have to go swim Olympics and do this all over again.
And you know, be away from my coach who I clung to.
You know, he wasn't able to come and be,
you know on the staff or anything like that.
And then be away from my parents for six weeks
which I'd never even been out of the country.
So I was, I was just turned 15 year old,
but I was a very naive,
looked like I was 12, 15 year old.
Just wasn't, just was in over my head.
Yeah, one of the things you talk about in your book is,
is like not exactly getting the kind of support
that you wish that you could have had as a young person.
Yeah, you know, and it's funny
I've talked to so many people at USA swimming,
now and they've been so great about saying like,
yeah like things are so different now
in the way that we support,
you know newcomers on the team.
Or even the, the building of the world junior team,
where it allows young people to go and travel the world as,
as a national junior teamer.
And they have that when I was at that age
but it wasn't as prolific.
It wasn't as,
hey you need to do this because those things matter
that experience helps you feel confident when you're
in a ready room with all these different people
from all these different countries.
To me, it felt like the hunger games
it just felt like happening.
But I think another thing is
I never now looking back I don't really expect it,
because everyone is facing their own struggles
coaches, athletes, and just the Olympics, it's the ultimate.
And so I think it's very difficult to
step outside of yourself and see
that someone else is struggling.
And there are people that did it.
And I shouted them out, Gary Hall Jr, Jason Lee's Zach.
To do that in that pressure cooker
that is the Olympic games, I think it's above and beyond.
And I, yeah, I do wish that maybe I'd had
someone understand what was going on and, and intervene.
Or if I had felt confident to say,
hey, I need some support.
I'm kind of floundering here,
but I just, I just don't think that
that was there at the time.
And I think that everyone was just trying to forge ahead.
Yeah, well, they're always thinking
about their own shit.
You know like they've got their own races to worry about,
do you, do you know who Alexi Pappas is?
Yeah, she was a guest.
So she is an Olympian track and field athlete
competed for Greece in the 10,000 meters, I think.
But she's also an actress, a writer, director producer.
And in the, and she made this film called Olympic Dreams.
That's a fictionalized account of
not really her story, but the story of a young female
athlete who goes to the winter Olympic games
as a cross country skier.
And has kind of a, not so great experience like,
and the emotions of like contending with that
where her coach is not there and she feels very alone.
And I just, when you're recounting that story
I was like, oh, you gotta watch this movie.
Yeah, I'm sure I can relate to it very much so.
Yeah looking back and even, I think being outside of it
you have conversations with people that make you go,
oh wow, how, how did I do that, you know.
Like people talk about like what they were doing at 15.
I'm about to walk out in a final or for the Olympics.
But in that moment, you're just it's fight or flight.
Like, am I gonna run or am I gonna face this, and
I just remember just terror, just full on terror,
just sitting there and like,
I used to do this thing where people would
if someone was walking by,
like I'd look at them and be like
I kind of wish I was like, just could trade places
with that person for just like, just like 10 minutes.
Like just for this race to be done.
Yeah, but you don't know what's going on
in that person's mind.
It could be the same thing,
it could be a nightmare inside, inside their head.
So not a good game, but that was just how much I
in that moment wanting to flee.
Like, it was just, I didn't I hadn't kind of developed
that system of confidence, and I feared the 400 IM
for the longest time.
Because I just felt like I had messed up so many times
or taking it out too fast and died.
And there was just like this,
I viewed it as like this mountain that just kept beating me
and I could never get back to the top.
Yeah, you don't end up meddling.
You get seventh in the 200 IM in 17th in the 400, right.
Throw up all over the pool deck.
What's that throwing up, that's okay, you know.
But the following year, I mean, look
you know Michael Phelps went to the Olympics at 15
and didn't mettle.
You know, people forget that.
Like they just think it's all goals all the time.
But when at his first Olympics,
you know I remember when that happened
and everyone's like, oh he's the future.
But it's not like he won a gold medal first time out.
So you go home and the following year,
you sign this like 10 year deal with Speedo and you go pro.
And suddenly you're buying cars and like handbags and stuff.
(Katie laughs)
And, and like, you know, it's all good, right.
The world is your oyster
because it's all gonna be about the next Olympics.
Yeah, yeah that was a, a crazy year
because, you know, I came home from Athens
kind of licked my wounds a little bit.
But there was never a feeling of like,
I'm done or I don't know if I can do this.
It was just redemption.
I was like, I want to show people that,
that wasn't a fluke that, you know just.
But it's interesting you use the word redemption.
Like what did you feel like you had to redeem,
because you didn't metal, like you were 15?
But that was for me,
that was, I had, I had flat out failed.
Like the, the art, the articles that were coming out
that I shouldn't have read.
I remember specifically, actually someone else told me this
'cause I didn't fully, I think I blocked it out.
But all the computers were in the basement, in the village.
And after the 400 IM masochistically go on and,
and look on the internet.
And I saw just this flurry of just negativity,
how I failed, and I fell on my face.
And just kind of lost it and burst into tears.
From like no name people or like rowdy and stuff.
From there, yeah.
There was a couple, there was a couple of people
that I, you know, very much looked up to
that were saying really, really hurtful things.
And that just, I'm so happy the social media was not
that way in 2004 because I don't know if I,
I think it would have been a lot harder to overcome.
You'd be in your dorm room scrolling.
Just look yeah.
And, and I think, you know, for the longest time,
the picture of me throwing up on the pool deck
at 15 years old was the first thing that popped up on images
when you searched my name.
And my parents had to like ask them to take it down,
you know at 15, that's.
Now 15 year olds are like well you know,
my hair is messed up in that one picture edited, right.
This was me just, so that was very traumatizing.
But yeah, I viewed it as I've let everybody down.
Like we had a party, I remember a welcome home party
when I got back and I was miserable.
I don't think people knew, but I didn't feel deserving.
I was like, which I know it's like,
when I say it it's crazy, but I was like, I failed.
Like, I didn't matter.
Even on seventh in the world at 15,
why are these people here?
Like everyone should just leave.
Like I need to get back to work and.
Yeah.
Redeem myself.
That's, you know and maybe that was.
And also the compartmentalization too.
Like that's in the past, I'm putting that away.
I'm moving forward.
Here's what I have in front of me to do.
Yeah, yeah and again, it worked for the time being,
it was, you know my coach Paul and I sat down
and it was like, all right,
well, a, you need to figure out how to not be fearful
of the 400 IM because it's truly messing with you.
Yeah, and that is terrifying.
(Katie and Rich laughs)
It's the most painful..
Like no one is in the ready room,
I have a joke with Elizabeth Beisel
who's in fellow Olympian 400 IM, amazing.
Got the silver in 2012.
And or we call it like the 400 IM stomach.
Like, it's just a very specific feeling before
and after that, if you were plopped
into a situation not having done the 400 IM
and someone was like, what's this feeling?
You'd be like, oh.
Somebody is gonna turn your insides out completely.
It's just, it's never gonna be,
whether it's an amazing race, a terrible race,
you gained 50 seconds you dropped 20,
is always gonna be the most painful thing ever.
And I actually have come up
and talking to one of our executives at my old company.
And I was like, yeah, it's the 400 IM analogy.
I was like, are you talking about like,
well you don't do the 400 IM because like,
if you, if you pretend in the, and the 400 IM
that you're like, yes I'm so excited as in this race.
If you're just, you're excited for the result.
But like, you're not,
if you pretend it's not there just pushing it down and,
and ignoring is almost more emotional energy
than just saying, wow, this is gonna suck
and this is super painful.
And that doesn't mean I'm being negative
because I'm doing this 'cause I'm trying to break records
and go best times.
But by to me, by embracing that in anything
and acknowledging it,
it makes it that much easier to attack and go after.
Right, but what you just said is like a corollary for,
for your life at the same time, right.
The idea of ignoring the difficulty
or the pain of the 400 IM is almost a stand in for
like that idea of how ultimately compartmentalizing
these things doesn't work out, right.
You have to like acknowledge, right.
(Katie laughs)
You're saying I just don't take my own advice.
No, I'm just saying like,
no, what I'm saying I think you're doing it now
but what you just said in terms of the 400 IM
is kind of what we're talking about
in terms of life as well.
Oh, for sure.
Yeah, I did not use the 400 IM analogy
when I stopped swimming, for sure.
Like I didn't turn and acknowledge things and yeah,
I did not take my own advice,
but in just the 400 IM situation.
I was good at acknowledging that, but you're right.
I think so many things that I did really well
in my career didn't necessarily translate and benefit
when something was done.
Right, so you're on your way though,
2007 you set your first world record in Melbourne.
You have your Natalie Coughlin moment, right.
Seven years after that idea was incepted into your brain.
And then in 2008, like here we go.
Like, everything becomes insane.
Yeah, it, and I could feel it building,
you know, it's like you're kind of like click, click, click,
and I hate roller coasters and I've been
manipulated and forced to be likable.
But it truly felt like that build up.
Rationing up.
Yeah, like 2007, I mean 2007
is probably one of my favorite years.
Just because everything, I felt like every time
I got in the water, it wasn't even like a question
in my mind, it was just like,
if I was behind, if I was not feeling great,
it was like, so.
Like I just knew, like I had this confidence
that it was just gonna happen.
And that, that feeling carried over,
you know into 2008 leading up.
But the problem was, it just kept building.
And I kept, every time I did a great swim or broke a record
or a restaurant with this, like dinky meat
and broke the American record in the 1650,
when it was supposed to just be a training, swim.
Like it was almost like even your event.
No, like it just kept, I kept coming going like,
what is happening?
Like everything's going well, but.
Who had that record?
Was that, was that a Janet Evans record?
It might've been, I don't know.
Like I wasn't, I remember like people
were making fun of me 'cause.
Now you sound like Caroline.
I know you're right.
I thought you would have known that.
I should have known, I should know.
'Cause it was the mile I wasn't even,
yeah, so it was that I almost was kind of
adding onto the expectation every time I got in
I'm breaking records and doing this.
Like each success just adds to the pressure
and the expectations that ultimately
you're gonna have to shoulder in Beijing.
Yeah, and I remember as, you know, six months out,
three months out you know, more interviews.
And I remember saying the words
but inside had kind of freaking out like.
And not knowing who to admit that to.
Because I was so like if I admit this,
like I'm kind of freaking out, like this is a lot,
like I haven't even won.
I have any one Olympic medal yet.
And everyone's swimming a lot of events.
Same as Michael, and I just remember thinking,
okay, like just take it one thing at a time.
At trials I'm summing a ton of events.
So we're saying even if everything goes wrong,
I'll at least make it in one event.
Like that was kind of like my,
what I'm saying.
Escape hatch.
Escape, yeah.
Like it will be okay.
But meanwhile, you're, you are starting to freak out.
Yeah.
And I feel like, I feel like sport has come a long way.
And even the last decade in terms of reckoning with
the mental aspects of elite performance and recognizing that
you know, coaches, parents, therapists,
whoever need to be you know, checking in more on
the emotional component here.
But maybe at that time, it hadn't gotten to that point.
And it's just like, are you good?
"Yeah, I'm good."
Okay, we've talked about that now, right.
Yeah.
Without really understanding like, oh man.
Like what's it like for a 19 year old
to suddenly be thrust into this position where
so much attention is being placed you know,
and expectations are, are being placed on you.
Yeah, and I think, you know, now talking to even
my parents you know, my parents were wonderful
throughout my career.
They were like, let me in the driver's seat,
they were supportive.
They, you know, my dad was the hype man.
You know, I'd come back from practice.
Like dad, I hit these paces.
He used to like "Yes, that's amazing."
My mom was the more sensible, real it in.
Like, it hasn't happened yet.
You know, she was the analytical one.
But I don't think my mom even says
now she's like I didn't know how to stop the train
from going as fast as it was.
It was just like, go, go, go, go, go.
But today shows here three months out,
I'm sitting down with Matt Lauer.
One-on-one like what was happening?
And you can see it, I watched that interview with him
for the first time when I put it in my book.
Like I'd never seen it.
And you can, I can just see the,
I can see what I'm saying where they can see
the look on my face and you can tell inside I'm like,
all right, you know.
Was that before trials or?
It was before trials.
Yeah, it was probably,
I think it was like six before trials.
He came and you know,
I just felt like there is the best analogy I always give
is like there's a barbell on my back, it's 45 pounds.
I can walk a lot around all day with that on my back.
But it was just like each day,
it was like here's that another five other five number five.
And you know, and I think I put so much emotional energy
as any athlete does into trials
because it was every single day,
you know, a big big events schedule out of the gate.
And that I remember finishing trials and going,
oh, I have to do that all over again.
Right.
Oh my gosh
So you go to trials, you qualified for individual events.
How many of those did you win?
Did you win all of them?
Yeah.
You won, you got for goals,
for first places at trials.
200 IM, 400 IM 200 free.
400 free, 800 free.
Oh, five event, five right.
And the only,
yeah it's like one of those stars aligning moments.
So those you're, you're no longer
getting five pound weights added onto that bar.
Like you're getting yeah, exactly.
I was just, it's almost like I was doing it to myself.
I mean, in a good way, right.
I was swimming out of my mind with
and so many of the races were close you know.
The 200 free I think it was seven, eight, one hundreds
in between me and then there was a super close race
in the 200 IM between Natalie and Ariana.
And so, and I'll never forget being so mad
because I did, the first day to the 400
the second day I did 400 IM,
the second day of the 400 free.
So two days in, I'm already four, four hundreds of racing in
the next two days, I have six to hundreds between the two.
Yeah, I think people that aren't familiar
with swimming don't understand.
It's not, you're not swimming five times.
You're swimming like 15 times or something, right.
Yeah, I think it was 15 times.
You have to swim you have to
swim prelim semi's and finals.
So maybe in the 800, do you do?
Prelims and finals.
There's only two for that, right.
There's only two for the 400 as well.
It was just, I mean, again, like the US is such a force
that there was no taking it easy
or you had to be A game,
you know when you're going into those people.
And so yeah, I left the trials,
I won five, I think Michael won five.
And the media was like, yes.
Right here, we have our,
we have our tightly knit narrative.
Like you are the female Michael Phelps, right.
That's a very easy story to tell.
It's very,
you know, it's very appealing to the to the public
because everybody wants to know who the other,
Michael, the female Michael Phelps is gonna be,
and you want five, you want five events.
It's like who else is gonna be, right.
Yeah, it was fare you know.
So here we go.
Yeah.
(Katie laughs)
It was fair but also if you, you know, obviously.
But it sets you up, if you don't win as many medals
as many gold medals as Michael, then you failed.
Yes, and I will say in my defense,
you know he was I think he had four world records
at that point of his, you know.
And I had one and it was,
I was trading the world record with
with another girl, Stephanie Rice.
And so I didn't feel like,
oh yeah like I'm going in ranked first and everything.
You know there were so many other competitors.
The public doesn't know that.
Good exactly, the public doesn't know that.
It doesn't know that.
Yeah, and we should also point out
that you're, that Michael was your teammate.
Like he's swam in NBAC and, and, you know.
the Olympics at 15, like too easy,
it was to easy.
(Katie and Rich laughs)
Did somebody asks you, like every single day
what it was like to swim with Michael Phelps?
Like I get that, it's literally like
line of questioning goes.
Oh, you swim, it depends on how curious.
Like you swim, oh my gosh.
Do you know Michael Phelps?
Do you know Michael?
Or sometimes did you swim?
And then assuming, you know, Michael Phelps
or they find out, oh, you swim in the Olympics.
Like, wait, I'm like, here we go.
Do you know Michael?
Yes, and then, so that's definitely, I think.
So how do you answer that?
I go yeah.
It depends on the company I would assume.
Depends on the company, I usually will just say yes.
And I always, I mean, Michael's an awesome guy.
And so I always, you know I think he's been through a lot
and there's a lot of things
that have happened in his career.
Good, and you know, maybe not so not so great.
And so I always use the opportunity to be like,
yeah he's an awesome guy and been through a lot.
And I always, I always liked to use the opportunity
to do that because sometimes I think it's similarly
very unfair how you know.
Can you imagine?
I mean, yes, you can.
You're one of the few people who can actually imagine
what that guy had to endure.
Of course, you know, there were gonna be moments
where he was gonna crack under that kind of pressure.
But what he's done in the wake of all of that
is so inspiring.
Very much so.
Yeah, he and I was
I was really happy to get to reconnect with him for my book.
And we were able to talk a little bit
because my heart feels so much for him
because like you said, I,
I can understand, but I can't
like I can understand a fraction
of what he feels
and just having been his teammate,
you know, in 09 we swam together
when he was going through a really tough time.
And so was I, but yeah,
I just think it's super unfair.
Sometimes the expectations
and the you know place we put certain people
on this pedestal and it's not fair.
It's just not fair.
Well, we'd like to put people on that pedestal.
We like to hoist them up.
And then we wanna look for how to pull them down
and any opportunity that we can.
You know people line up for that.
Unfortunately that's the way culture works.
Yeah.
But then we also like when they come back.
They but back.
And he's done that as well.
So, you know what I mean?
Yeah.
All right so,
you go to Beijing
with just this unbelievable
amount of pressure and expectations being placed on you.
And you talk about this in the book, like
things don't they don't go to plan.
You end up walking away with three medals
out of this experience
but you don't get any golds and,
you know you fail to make the final and the 800 free
like things just didn't
work out the way that they could have
and maybe they should have, I don't know.
Like how do you look back on that
and think about that time.
Yeah, I think,
I think I always wonder, you know, if
if the 400 IM
had gone maybe a little better
like what if I had, what if I had won gold
in the 400 IM.
Right, like you got, you got silver
you were basically touched out.
The four to three yeah.
I got touched out
but the 400 IM actually look at the 400.
I was one of my best swims of the me
because yes, I got bronze,
but I was within a half a second
of the time I did at trials
which was the time that
broke the world record at the time.
And it was just on that day.
But those other two girls
like went under 430 for the first time right.
And, and I remember in the race thinking
I must be doing terribly because
there you know, I can, I can't even see,
you know she's two seconds ahead of me.
And then when I touched, I go, oh, okay.
Like that actually was a great swim for me.
But instead of thinking that way, you know
you go through the little mixed zone
right after you finished and it's, are you happy?
Like the media is questioning me, you know
what are you, are you, are you good with that?
You got bronze, you know, right at the gate.
And then, you know
it didn't really have the support I needed from
from coaches, from my coach afterwards.
And so I think that really started the me
off on the wrong foot.
And it felt like, I think
after that I started scrambling
and you know, the 400,
I got touched out funny enough
the 203 I break the American record.
I go a best time.
I just happens to be that I got fourth.
And once again, so every time I kind of had a good,
wow that was a really good swim for you personally.
It was what happened.
That was a failure you didn't won gold.
And do you just feel like that, that
that Boulder is rolling downhill in the wrong direction.
Like there's a momentum with that right, yeah.
For sure, just, yeah just like.
And you can't catch your breath
because like every session
you've got one or two swim.
Yeah and I think that's
that's actually where compartmentalizing skill came in.
That came in handy.
Because it was like
every time something happened, it was just
you literally have three hours
until you need to go back to the pool
and you need to get up again
and go for it and, you know, represent your country.
But there were times where I'm
caking on eyeliner because I had just bawled my eyes out
and I didn't want them to be puffy.
(Katie laughing)
Some people saw it crying.
Yeah, but you talked about how
you hate the, you know, like
when you parade around the deck
and you gotta wave and like smile and all of that.
And you're like, I'm just here to race, man.
I don't wanna do this dog the pony show.
I wish was more like, I just
I remember, I remember talking about that with someone
they were like, then why do you wave?
I'm like, well, that's what people want.
Right, if you don't, then they're like
what's wrong with her?
Yeah, like, what's wrong with that girl?
She must be cold you know.
She's not a Patriot.
Yes. (Katie laughing)
I always would kind of like,
all right, here we go.
I'm gonna smile and, and, you know, wave.
But yeah, like I, at that, you know
I was kept goggles on first.
I wanted my stuff off first
so I could be behind the blocks, like the first one.
So I was extra ready.
And Beijing was the pinnacle
of the fast scan, super suit era, right?
Yeah, the, I feel like Speedo
open Pandora's box with
you know, and then all the other suits came with.
So it was like a crazy onslaught of world records.
Just being set all over the place.
And everybody realized
maybe this wasn't such a good idea.
They've really put that back in the box though.
I would have thought, well, once that's out,
like there's no way we can go backwards.
We really did.
We did.
Yeah it just kind of like.
And all those records have been broken since.
Yeah yeah pretty much so that's.
Yeah, that I think that also normalized, like,
okay so you get an American record
in the true free, well, what's that.
You know, like I think to the American public
because it was like world record world record every second
it normalize it, that people
didn't think that was anything special.
I mean, I didn't in the moment
I didn't even know someone was like,
I mean, I had it so it was just going a best time.
But someone had to remind me like,
Hey, I think that was
but I had the 200, I am 30 minutes later.
So we have time to, to think, or, you know,
even understand how it was feeling
how it's supposed to feel.
So when does it all land on you?
Like when you're, when you're done swimming
and you have the opportunity to go, what just happened?
I think about 50% of the way when I
was, so I checked out of the village
when we were done with racing, everything.
Cause 04 I was shipped home immediately.
You're right you were too young to handle.
I'm too young to handle.
But the village.
The village.
Shenanigans.
All that stuff.
So this time I was like helping.
I was like, oh, I am staying, I'm enjoying.
I wanna stay at the events.
I wanna go out with everybody.
And so I checked out and I think, I, I, again
I was shoving things down because
I'm like, well, right.
You know, sponsors stuff to do.
I had to smile.
And I remember the next day we had an event with Speedo.
and I remember having these brief fleeting moments
of like, oh, like, I don't feel like I belong here.
Like I was looking around
and looking at Natalie and Michael
and Ryan and all these people that had won gold medals.
And I'm like, okay
well who's the person who's that outsider me.
Like, I always felt that way.
And then I remember, okay, well, like,
just forget about it You need to enjoy.
So I'd have these moments of sadness,
like in my hotel room, by myself and,
and then we would go out
and then we would go
to different events and I would smile
but it was still like,
I wasn't allowing myself to feel.
And then I remember coming home.
I don't feel like I ever fully grieve,
to be honest with you.
Like now that I'm thinking about it
I think it was just moments here and there
where I would feel off
or I'd have this pit in my stomach, or
I would do an interview
with another athlete
and just feel like not good enough.
Like, and I would always go by gold medal.
Like, I'm like, why have a silver.
They have a gold.
So, and it didn't even hit me
that I felt that way until I watched
the winter Olympics and they announced someone
and they were like silver medalists.
I was like, wow, she's a badass.
And I remember like, oh, I have a silver,
like, that's that's how people look at that.
But at the time, you know.
I would get picked up by a car service
and he would be like, oh an Olympian,
you know, like, did you win gold?
And I would have to say no.
Or it would be like, did you win a medal?
That's the first question.
Yeah, I did.
Did you win gold?
No, oh, bummer.
You know, and that would just
I was like a dagger to the heart for me in that.
Right, the car service guy has an opinion.
Great you know, and at that point it was so fragile.
Can you move up to the expectations
of the guys giving you a ride.
(Katie laughs)
So my life must be meaningless.
But at that point I was so fragile with all of that,
that anyone, I mean it didn't matter if it was
an armchair critic.
It didn't, like I was just so fragile and then
at the same time I was, you know deciding whether
I was gonna move the coach, move from the coach
that got me to two Olympics.
So it was tough.
Yeah, I mean, in the wake of 2008,
I mean, basically the next six years
are just kind of fits and starts.
Like you're moving around a lot,
you're switching coaches, you're you stop working with Paul
you start working with Bob, you moved to Florida
to pick it back up with Paul again.
And then you're in Los Angeles living with Caroline
and the whole Sean Hutchinson thing
and John or band check and all of that.
And just, it just feels like,
I mean, I don't know that we need to kind of go through
every aspect of that.
But my sense of it is just fits and starts
where you can't really find your groove, right.
And just, it's never really clicking.
You have moments where you feel
like you're on your way back and you,
you have a race where you're you know, in good form
but it never really comes together for you.
And that's a long, that's a lot of years to be kind of
feeling like out of tune with,
you know, the way that you used to feel
where everything was just firing on all cylinders.
Yeah, that was tough.
And now looking back, you know
you do that analysis, like, could I have done differently?
I mean, I really think a lot of it was that I just,
I had so much emotional baggage
that it just kept resurfacing.
And I just don't think, you know I ever
built that confidence back.
But you know 2008, felt like
I had the wind knocked out of me.
2009 I fought all the way from,
I don't even make a, you know
Olympic or world championship team
which was the next team the year later.
So then it was like sink further.
I just felt like I was like in this hole
and like dirt was continually coming in
and I was trying to claw my way out,
and I just never feel like I did.
And then all the while feeling again,
feeling like walking around the pool deck feeling like
I just don't like, people must be thinking that way.
People must be thinking, oh, she's washed up, she's.
That's a lot of energy to expand on that too.
You know, like I think in hearing you say that,
I wonder what do you think would have happened if after O8
you just took a whole year off.
And you had a coach who said,
"I'm not even letting you get in the water
until we like process everything that happened."
And we're gonna work through all of this
and I'm not letting you off the hook.
And you just.
I feel that's
the best thing ever.
And then, and then like a year later
you just started a very slow rebuilt.
It would've seemed, it would have been impossible
because you would have been like there's no way
I'm sitting out of the water for a year, like.
I'm not gonna remember how to swim.
I'm not saying it ,saying it was feasible,
but just as an academic exercise,
you know, as a thought experiment.
Yeah, I think it would have been
probably one of the healthiest things I could have done.
Because you know, I finished 2009
and I almost, I almost thought about stopping, like I was.
Of course.
(Katie laughing)
I know shocking.
But at the time I thought like,
why am I doing this to myself?
Like, I am flat out miserable.
I'm crying every single day.
Like it just wasn't.
And you have three medals from the Olympics.
Yeah, yeah I didn't even want, I mean
they were like in like a little like bag like
in my nightstand like that, I just didn't wanna.
My name is Katie Hoff and I have three Olympic medals
and I'm ashamed of myself, welcome to my Ted talk.
That's such a great opening Ted Talk
I don't wanna give you credit for that one.
But yeah, I just you know, and all the while I'm going,
I'm still, you know I'm working with sponsors.
I'm going talking about the Olympics and how amazing it is
and like how much I love everything.
And again, forwarded, I am analogy.
I'm not, I'm pretending I'm just pretending and
it just was not healthy.
Yeah, do you, how do you think about
the decision that you made to go pro at 16?
Like, is there a part of you that wishes,
like you'd just you'd gone to college
and had the whole institute experience?
You know, I think there's, there's definitely,
I mean the grass is always greener, right.
Like I think there's positives and negatives to both.
The decision to go pro early,
I feel actually really good about.
Because I think you know, while I didn't have,
I do, you know the teammates that you make
on a college team I think are forever,
you know the friendships you build.
But I also feel like I built I have such,
I mean, my wedding five of the six women
in my wedding party were summers
and four of them were Olympians.
So I think I've built those bonds.
But I think the experiences of getting to go pro early
because I didn't know at the time
but I wasn't gonna be swimming and,
you know sponsored into my thirties
to work with some of the companies I worked with,
the experiences I got.
You know, getting to go on a tour of, of China with visa.
You know, there's so many memories that I think I had
and that really shaped me as a person
that I actually really think was valuable
to me as a person and in my career.
And I don't actually think that that's,
there wasn't a lot of pressure during that time
because I always looked at it like,
well, I'm I'm gonna be trying
to go after these things anyways.
So why not, you know be compensated
for the performances that I'm doing.
But I definitely think that would have made
what you just said of taking the year off really difficult.
Yeah.
Because in that.
Well, Speedo wouldn't have allowed that.
I mean, that's why I said it's not, it wasn't feasible.
Like you know.
Yeah, It would have been nice.
Right, but I think because of these experiences
it gives you a resonance that allows you
to be really helpful to the next generation of athletes
or just to people in general.
Like, hey I have a black belt, you know, in disappointment.
And I know what it's like for my life to peak
essentially at 17 and try to figure out
what I'm gonna do.
Yeah, it's, you know what I was talking to my mom
the other day, I'm like, I feel like I've ripped
off the bandaid so many times
in just putting myself out there
and just failing in a really large.
I know it sounds.
It's not failure though.
It's not failure but
no, all right I'll rephrase that.
Putting myself out there and not living up
to my expectations of what I was hoping the result would be.
And so I feel like now I'm I have a level of fearlessness
where I'm like, well if it doesn't work out,
I know I'll get back up
because I've done it time and time again.
And I think sometimes people who haven't gone through that
have this fear and I've watched people close to me
or people I know not make decisions,
or not take actions because they they do have that fear of
what if it doesn't work out, like how am I gonna respond,
what am I gonna do?
I'm just like, well.
(Katie laughs)
You could be well, yeah, but what's beautiful
about your experiences is you can say,
listen I know what it's like when the whole world decided
that I was gonna be X and I failed to live up to that.
And they all had opinions on that.
Like, you're never gonna be under that kind
of a white hot spotlight again in your life.
So you're kind of disaster proofed, right.
Yes, yes.
Right, you know what I mean?
And there, there's a liberation in that
if you look at it through that lens to say,
hey man, like I did that deal.
And I serve, not only did I survive that
like I learned a lot about myself
and I can take those lessons and apply them in my life now
and be fearless in what I'm doing.
Because, because I've realized now that
all of those people's expectations and opinions
are actually meaningless.
This is about the relationship
between me and me and what I want.
Yes, I have expectations that I set for myself
and I will either live up to them
exceed them or fall short of them.
But it has nothing to do with,
you know the peanut gallery of, of the public.
Yeah, yes and I think that's something that,
I mean, you're talking to you within the last year
that it's clicked.
Like that's, I wouldn't even be able to come
on this podcast even two years ago.
Like I just, I kind of put all those things together
through writing the book,
self-discovery, lots of conversation.
And that was such a freeing and wonderful moment
to have of okay, like my life makes sense.
Like it makes, I just wanted it all to make sense.
Like if I was gonna go through some tough times
and some painful times,
I wanted to make sense for right now.
I think that was always kind of my,
how can I have resolution with,
you know everything was gone on the good, the bad, the ugly.
and that right, what you just said has done that to,
to feel like, yes there's gonna be lots of curve,
more curve balls in life.
I'm 31 years old, but okay.
Throw on my way, because I've, I've gone through,
I've taken some shots and I've, I'm still standing.
Yeah, well, when I was 31, I was in rehab.
Okay.
(Katie and Rich laughs)
No, in all seriousness, I think, you know in
in reading your book, the sense that I got
and I think you said it earlier is
my take is even if nobody read this book
and this was just a personal diary entry for you,
my sense in reading, it was,
oh, this is the first time that she's
she's doing this because she's trying to figure
out how to work through these things.
And, and some of this stuff, if not, most of this stuff
is stuff she's never spoken about publicly
or admitted to anybody, right.
And that in and of itself is so it's such a cathartic
experience and so necessary to the growth trajectory
that you're on.
Yeah, and I fought it.
Like I tried to, I tried to start my,
on my on own a couple of times.
And every time it would end in just tears.
It's like, okay clearly not ready for this yet.
And then I finally got connected to the ghost writer.
And even then, like I submitted
here's my 40 pages that I've written.
And he was like, "That's pretty surface level."
Like, all right, yeah, you're right.
I need a coach, like I need someone who's going to be like,
dig deeper say more.
You know, because I I'd never gone there,
and I knew I needed to, when it was about a month before
I finally decided can quitting my corporate job,
I'm gonna write this book.
I'm ripping off the bandaid.
And I was with my husband Todd, and his aunt
and she was really pushing.
She was like, I just like, why would you not write a book?
Like I do not write a book.
And I was just like I don't feel like anyone's gonna
like, again the silver metal thing is in my head.
And I just, I kept, I felt very
I don't know if she knows this, but I felt very pushed.
I felt very into a corner.
And we were in New York and we had a long,
we were living in New Jersey at the time and we Ubered back
and I like without even being able to control it
just burst into tears, like blubbering tears.
Like where you just can't control it.
And I was like, what just happened?
I was like, I just, I can't, I can't, I can't, you know
I just like had this, and I was like surprised at myself
because I cry a lot.
But I cry when a happier cry when I'm mad
but it was just this like uncontrollable thing.
15 years are 20 years of hands up,
you know, compartmentalized emotion.
Yeah, and he was just like, looking at me like,
what's wrong, I was like, I don't know, I don't know.
And then I thought about it more
and it was kind of final, like straw.
It was just like, yeah, like I need to do this.
Like, it's gonna really suck
and it's gonna be really hard.
Like Todd knew he'd be like, what year are you in?
Like, if I was like in a good mood while we were writing,
he was like, you're in a good year.
If I was in it's like, you're in like 2009, 2010.
But yeah, you know, it was like that.
It was like working through
things I wouldn't even talk about in therapy obviously.
Like, I feel like my ghost it was like a kind of filter out
everything but I unloaded everything for eight months.
So it was just like a eight month long therapy session
that turned into a book, which was pretty cool.
Yeah, and, and I would suspect feeling like
lighter in your shoes.
Yeah, lighter for a while.
And then right before the book was gonna come out
I was like, oh my gosh, I feel naked.
So what do you might read this?
(Katie laughs)
I feel really exposed because you know,
and even like the little sections in the book
those were really vulnerable like little excerpts
because the girls are had asked me
each week to like a team gave me three topics.
And he was like, you pick what you want and you free flow.
And just let it come from, come from within, not thinking.
I was like, oh cool.
Like, he's gonna get to know my psyche better
and get to know me.
So I'm just gonna be really honest.
Not thinking that we were going to actually put that
in the book and publish it.
Only as I was like, you know what,
yes, like if I'm not gonna make this the most vulnerable
authentic thing ever, then I don't wanna publish it.
Right, it's no good unless you do that anyway.
Yeah, it's surface level.
But it's scary.
The day before I was like, okay, here we go.
You know, and people will, you know feel what they feel
and hopefully it's positive or hopefully it helps
people through something.
And I think the biggest compliment I've ever,
I've been given so far is people gifting it
to someone who's going through a tough time
and saying like, read this book, this, this will help.
And that's.
That's cool.
Really cool.
Yeah, so with that in mind, what is the advice
that you would give to your 15 year old self
or your 19 year old self,
like being on the other side of this,
could you have spared yourself some of the anxiety
and consternation, like what is it about
competition at that level that, you know
people don't understand that you wish,
you know your young self kind of understood better?
I think the one piece is to stopping
and I know sounds so cliche, but just stopping for a second
and be in being in the moment, like I never stopped.
It was just like, check the box check the box,
check the box.
Even at trials, which was in 2008
which was probably the best meal of my life.
I breaking world records.
Five for five.
Five for five, like I didn't,
it was next thing next thing, next thing it wasn't.
Wow, oh my gosh like, this is really cool.
And I don't know how I would have,
I don't know how I would've done that
because that's, again, the byproducts.
Right, 'cause if you're enjoying it, then you're
it is a weird thing, like, can you have it both ways?
I don't, yeah, I don't.
And I know like there's people I've seen my,
like for example Katie Ledecky.
I don't, I don't know her super well,
but I know her you know, we've had conversations
and I'm very envious of how she has carried herself.
She's seems.
She seems to have it very in check.
Yes, and I'm sure there's, you know
she has them all and she's human, but I think
I was always so all over the place and next thing
and robotic that I don't like from me,
just from the age of 10 when it was just like,
okay, like systematic here's what I'm doing.
That's why I made my comeback for 2016 because
I'm like did I even enjoy a second at the Olympics?
Like everyone said, oh my God was the Olympics so much fun.
I used to be like, yeah.
And now I'm like, no, it was just really stressful.
(Katie and Rich laughs)
Now, I'm honest.
No, that was the thing about, yeah,
the comeback was all about like,
I wanna have this experience and be able
to be present and enjoy it and not be so, you know,
insanely attached to the results.
But that's when the whole blood clot thing happens
the pulmonary embolism.
And you're like, I could try to struggle through this
but that is at odds with the whole reason you,
you got back into it again.
Yeah, that was kind of, I think that was not a punch.
I thought, whatever I mean
I was very fortunate in my swimming career.
I never really had any injuries, like a groin pull here
shoulder tendonitis there, nothing crazy.
So to finally get into the mode of, yeah,
I'm gonna, I'm gonna make a comeback.
I'm gonna do this.
You know, I found a coach.
That was, it was just very much of a partnership
at that point.
You know, I'm 24 years old, I'm a student of the sport.
Like I was very, always very curious about sets.
So I felt confident to be like, yeah, we should do this.
And it was a really cool collaboration
first time in my career.
And meanwhile, women are competing older and older.
We have Dara Torres and Amanda Beard
and all these people who are killing it.
So you're, you're certainly still very much,
you know in the midst of being able
to achieve peak performances.
Yeah, and I think, and of course
the one thing that I felt alluded by was that goal model.
And in my mind, I'm thinking, okay, the US is always strong
on the four by 200 freestyle relay.
To be honest I don't think I, I knew I was realistic.
Like I knew, okay, I'm not gonna go
and like win five events at trials.
Right, just pick one or two.
Just like, yeah, just pick one or two enjoy.
Of course, the two events I'm best at the time turned IM
and turned her free fall on the same night.
I was like, I'm not 19 anymore.
I'm not gonna do that double.
I'm gonna go with, you know.
I had to pick, I was going to have to pick
She wanted to be on a relay.
So you got to the 200 free.
Yeah, I think those were the winning dots
to be honest with you.
Yeah, but I, yeah, I just remember feeling so,
and it was really cool to have, you know
the guy that had just proposed to me
and to have him a part of that as well.
He was training me outside of the pool.
I've heard cause he was a trainer
and it was just really like all I wanted.
I was like, God, if I could get Anderson Caps
I'd have a Hoff and Anderson cap.
Like that would be so special to be able to have that.
So I just felt for the first time balanced
and I was enjoying things and I was swimming lights out.
Like I was swimming times.
I used to pace, you know, in, in the peak of my training.
And so to go to, you know, the year out is 2000
or year and a half out to is in 14 nationals.
And, you know, have this pain that I was initially
told was an intercostal strain was devastating.
Like, I, I didn't know what was wrong with me.
I thought I was weak, I'll never forget someone was like,
"Oh, yeah I had a strain the other day like that."
And they're like, acted like, you know
what's wrong with you you can't.
Right, you were just misdiagnosed
For seven weeks
For extended period of time.
Yeah, and I remember thinking like, well,
maybe I'm as tough as I thought, like.
You know, maybe I just totally doubting my whole mindset
and then to be diagnosed with you know,
two of them on the bottom of my right lung.
It still didn't really dawn on me.
Like now looking back, like I flew six hours
with blood clots in my lungs,
like could have easily died
And it feels knives in your chest, right super painful.
Oh it's, I mean, it started out kind of just like a cold
and then it went to, yeah, like literally someone's
like stabbing you and I couldn't even take an air.
So I passed out.
My poor fiance is having to figure out like,
well, do I call the ambulance?
And she's going to get an IV,
which without a TUE is disqualification to meet
or do you know we just figured this out.
And him being an elite athlete.
Like I think most people probably listening to this.
They're like, yeah you call the ambulance
because she's passed out.
But he knew that this was everything,
so I didn't wanna be disqualified.
And so, yeah, I'll never forget kind of just holding
out hope that I could still compete to make,
you know the world's team, which is really the setup
for the Olympics in 2016.
And I just looked up and I was like, you guys have
to say get out of the pool
because I know if I got out of the pool it means.
This is done and I'm not gonna be able to do this.
And then yeah, kind of then relief getting the diagnosis
of the pulmonary embolism
because at least I know what's wrong with me.
I'm not a ramp.
Like they're like getting this wheelchair.
Ma'am I'm like, no, I haven't been training
for seven weeks without a wheelchair.
I'm not getting in a wheelchair.
They admitted me to the hospital.
And then yeah, like I kind of just tried to fight it
and thought maybe I can get my training shorter.
So when that happens, is it like a chronic thing,
it recurs or what's the situation with that?
It's not, it's not an isolated thing.
Like, oh, I had these clots
but now they're gone and I'm fine.
Well, it kind of depends on the person.
So I had every blood test under the sun
in terms of does this run in your family?
You know do you have some type of,
you know, disease not disease
but some type of mutation where it's gonna happen again.
And they couldn't really find anything.
So I still don't really know how they have it.
But do you go out, so you go on blood thinners,
but is that forever, or how does that work?
So you on blood thinners,
essentially your body kind of dissolves the clots itself.
And then you go in and they kind of decide like,
do you, are you on blood clot or blood thinners for life,
or are you able to go off them and just be conscious?
And that was ultimately mine.
I was on there for three years and now I'm just conscious.
And obviously with I'm not pregnant or anything
but with pregnancy in my future,
I'll have to be careful 'cause that's.
Right, but you haven't had a recurrence of it.
No, no.
But then you had your thymus taken out, right?
Like you had an like what happened?
So I feel like that was also.
'Cause that's weird.
Like is that related or?
I feel like it's related, and I think I was probably
so rude in the hospital because
it was really hard to accept this.
Okay, this happened, we don't know how,
there was no resolution and I'm still struggling.
You know, there was scar tissue built up in my lungs was,
I was still feeling, I was still dying at the end of races
at the end of sets going,
what do you said it was gonna be fine?
And so then my thymus gland
was twice the size it was supposed to be.
So they thought it was potentially cancerous.
They, they removed it and I wanted the doctor come in
and say, that's probably what caused the clots.
Now you're all good.
Like I had this very big hope
that they would be like you're fine.
You can return to normal, you can return to training.
This was the issue that was making it hard
for you to breathe.
Any essentially said the opposite.
He was like, "Well, it's gonna be really tough, you know to,
to have a full lung capacity to make an Olympic team again.
But at least you're, you're alive.
And to me that was like, what if I said that to you doctor?
Like, well, you can't be a doctor anymore
but at least you're alive, like that's.
The thymus is, I mean,
I don't know that much about the thymus
but it's super important to immunity when you're young
but as you age, right, it becomes less
it becomes like this, this sort of dormant gland.
But I would imagine it's still plays some role.
Like it can't be innocuous to just remove it
especially when you're trying to be an elite athlete.
Yeah, I mean, I would, I would think
and I would think there'd be,
I don't know if it was causation or correlation
to why I would have,
like, if it was double again I'm not a doctor.
So I have no idea.
But if it was double in size,
wouldn't that affect my body's ability to.
Right, if it was double insight, was it,
was it producing some kind of, you know,
immunity response that was working at odds with
your ability to recover or you know, who knows.
I don't know, I sound like an idiot right now.
(Katie and Rich laughs)
We can make it all day long.
I was sitting there doing the same thing.
But like, if your thymus is twice the size
like something's off, something's wrong.
Yeah.
And when we're dealing in a world of,
of hundreds of seconds, you know, making a difference,
I can't imagine that there wasn't some kind of
impact on you physically.
Yeah, 'cause I didn't,
I mean talk about not feeling yourself.
Like I was, I did not feel myself.
I could not train the same way that I trained
right before nationals in 2014 and you know yeah.
Like it was, it was misery.
I was not myself.
I didn't wanna see people,
I didn't wanna go to dinner.
I didn't, like, I just was so upset
that I had, again, you know, taking this risk
decided to come back into swimming and then it was like, no.
It's in and then that's ultimately,
I was like, what what am I doing?
Like you're repeating the cycle, you're repeating it again.
You know, like I need to close this
because I'm not even, I'm like a shell of myself,
in terms of misery.
And to do it kind of, you know, anonymously
with this sort of, you know, you're kind of saunter off
you know, without anybody really paying attention.
Like it's so far outside of the spotlight at this point,
based upon, you know, where you, where you were in 2008.
Yeah, and.
That's gotta be, that's had to be hard.
Yeah, I remember like,
well I remember yeah.
Saying I'm like, is anyone even gonna care?
Like, you know, like I remember being frustrated
because no one saw the times
that I was doing in practice before.
No one knew other than my coach,
maybe Todd my parents and myself,
what kind of times I was doing.
And the meats I was doing well too but
it just felt very, like I just kinda got like short changed.
And that was also a piece I was very resentful of,
you know, culmination obviously
everything we've talked about.
But that having end like that, I was like, oh my God.
Right, like so much unfinished business.
And how do you move forward and not allow like that,
that resentment to fester and, you know,
basically manifest in all kinds of ways
that would not serve you.
Yeah, so many different ways.
Being an angry person to be, you know,
all I mean really like it's like a,
it's a serious thing I would think.
Yeah, I mean, there were just
so many breakdowns and so many and I,
and I didn't really like most people
really it was just taught that
in my family that knew like poor guy,
he was going through his own, you know,
he just finished his football career.
So we were both.
So how many years did he play pro?
So he only played till, say I had a cup of coffee
in the league.
So he played for a year.
He was a walk-on how to out a pretty bad hamstring injury
ended up getting caught after a year.
But he, you know, he was,
his career was actually the opposite.
Like he was a walk on at Michigan State.
He kind of was just on this like up,
I'm like I'm kind of jealous of your, just like trajectory.
But he was awesome.
So he, so everybody's underestimating him.
He's exceeding everybody's expectations.
(Katie and Rich laughs)
He's like, yeah but I didn't reach the high I'm like,
I don't care, I don't care.
Like sometimes we got cut.
But still you're there's a shorthand there, right.
So he didn't end up having some super
smashing successful pro football career.
And you're able to have,
like he's gonna be able to understand
where you're coming from almost better than anybody.
Yeah, and he, you know
there's so many times where it's just like,
God you need to go see a therapist, like, like this is
this is manifesting itself in, you know.
I would have like the random breakdowns or,
you know it just wasn't, and I don't think anyone really.
Yeah, no how could anyone understand.
But I really kept it hidden and people just kind of like
kind of just disappeared, like from the swimming.
Like when I came back last year, we were like,
oh nice to have you back in the swimming world.
You know, because I just couldn't stand to be in front
of a group of kids and say, yeah, like swimming is fun.
And I'm like, I'm lying.
Like, I don't know how to frame my career
'cause there are positive things.
There's are so many positive things
but how do I do it in a way that's constructive
and helpful and vulnerable all at the same time.
Like I had no idea how to do that.
And so I think people who probably I'm sure people
who from outside the swimming world saw me,
they're like, what is wrong with her?
Like, why is she, why can't she find,
why can't she be satisfied?
Or, you know, why is she look upset
or you know there's so many times where I felt
like I just was terrible at handling my emotions.
Well, I also think there are institutional failures
or like systemic blind spots.
Like I feel like it's incumbent upon USA swimming
or the organizational bodies of all the sports
to do a better job of creating
mental health programs around.
You know not just how you deal with failing
to live up to your own expectations
but how you make this career transition.
Or, you know some kind of,
of programming around the emotional and mental aspects
of elite competition.
Because it's stressful and it's anxiety producing.
And I would say the vast majority of athletes
who are competing at the highest level at some point are,
are faced with very serious mental health challenges.
And there's no infrastructure set up
around how to best manage that.
Everybody's sort of left to their own devices
and some fall and some, you know, make their way through it.
But just saying, oh, here's your meditation app
or go to the meditation room or,
you know maybe you should talk to somebody.
I think is inadequate, and I think it it's now it's 2021.
Like let's take this seriously.
And let's put some time and intentionality
and some funding behind figuring out
how to support young people all the way
through the process so that when they
get to the Olympic games and they've qualified
in five events, they're mentally fit to handle it.
Because they've been dealing
with this in lockstep all along.
Agreed, yeah and it's funny 'cause I
feel like now it's mental health is so prolific
in what everyone talks about.
And I've been asked a lot recently, like,
well was there a, you know, where did you get support?
Did you get, you know people reach out to you.
The extent of I'll never forget we did this Navy Seal day.
All right, you talked about this.
And you know, walking off and having this.
This made you mad.
So mad, thing like.
You know, this whole crazy day where we're,
you know in fatigues in this freezing cold water
and getting screamed at and doesn't
that make the form that I am seemed
so much easier like mentally.
Like no, no like that.
No and, and I, you know, I think I do take part
responsibility, right.
Like you have to also be willing to accept help, right.
And you have to have.
Right, the problem is sorry to step in.
But I think that a big problem,
and this has come up with
a lot of athletes that I've
talked to on the podcast.
Your whole life is premised on not admitting weakness.
Like you could not admit
because that is, you know, antithetical
to the performances you're trying to execute on.
Right, like, I'm good.
Like I am strong.
I am impervious and I can handle this.
Yeah you can.
Yeah. I mean the same thing, reason why I never
wanted to admit out loud how terrified I was for Beijing.
You know, it's like by saying it out loud it by saying
I have a problem or I'm not, I'm not doing okay.
I'm not handling this well out loud just makes it real.
And I think, yeah
But the truth is it's real.
Whether you admit it or not.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes, it's affecting you, it's affecting your mood
and your actions and your relationships.
And so I think, yeah, I think
I think making it more normalized to, you know
I went into my whole, I mean
I feel like some people talk to each other
but I didn't want to admit to some of my friends
or my colleagues, what I was going through or, or why.
And, and, and for mine
I always felt so not the word is how can I say
to people I'm upset or I'm not at peace with my career.
You know, I want to say, well, you want three medals.
You want us to ha but yeah.
But when you're being called a female, Michael Phelps
and you're supposed to win multiple, that is a fail.
That's a really hard thing to phrase
and say without sounding like you're ungrateful
or do you know what I mean?
Like, it's something that I I've needed to lean on people.
Like, how do I say this?
Or do you understand what I mean?
Or do you understand?
You know, and it's been a few people in my life
even Jesse, honestly, I've had, I had a couple conversations
with him about just the transition and
and how I felt so strange in corporate life.
And, and what did he say to you?
He was like, yeah, of course.
Of course not.
You know, I just made me feel so understood
and he doesn't notice, but we, like
we drove away and I actually like got really emotional
because I was like, oh my gosh, I just felt so understood.
And for so long I felt like, it's me again
like you put it on yourself, like, it's for sure me, like
I'm the person who leaves a conversation or leaves an event.
And I like, all right, let, let me recount that whole thing
and just analyze how I handle that.
And like, you know, make sure like, I'm, self-aware enough
to know like if I've messed up or if I didn't, you know
handle that conversation right.
And so I always felt like the after part was like
I'm not patient enough or I'm not framing this right.
Or I just, I and I, people had people say that to me
you know, like I'm not, I'm not satisfied.
Well, yeah that's just cause like,
you know, you gotta wait your turn you know.
And I'm like, who is super successful?
That is patient.
Like, yes, you have to wait for time, but you're
always forging ahead and, and, you know, wanting
to keep going.
And I just felt so like, it's me, like, I
I think that maybe I just have been in this swimming bubble
for so long that I just don't know what it's like
in the real world.
I convinced myself of this narrative and I just need to
I just need to change and figure it out.
And hopefully eventually I'll start to feel better and
Right, and the problem with that is you're very good
at finding that, what did you call it?
The deeper gear, like the right.
Yeah so you can find the deep down gear
and you can grind it out right.
And you know, you can
you can like sublimate whatever emotions you have
around that and just grind.
But ultimately that's an unsustainable path, right.
Unsustainable.
Because you're like, well, it worked in swimming
and this is what I got to do now that I'm retired
and you're gonna run into a brick wall at some point.
And the good news is, is you've kind of done that.
And you've learned from that experience.
And, you know, as Jesse said
I would say to you as well, like it's not you, it's just
about finding that lane that, that, that fits with
you know, the values that you're coming to terms with.
And I think the fact that you're owning, you know, this path
that you're on and the past that you've had, and simply
by den of talking about it right, is like so powerful.
And it gives so many other people permission to recognize
you know, their own version of that pain
or disappointment that they've experienced in their lives.
And that's how we move forward.
Like, I'm sure you saw the weight
of gold documentary that Michael produced
like this conversation is happening.
It's long overdue, but it's happening now.
And I think it's going to have, you know
this ripple effect of, of healing across generations from
you know, the eight year old version of yourself
to the parents who are trying to guide young people
through their own athletic or entrepreneurial
or it is career.
Yeah, it's, it's really exciting and refreshing just
to see where things are headed.
I mean, with my own, but the way I'm able to even talk
to girls, I mentor or talk to the athletes that we work
with in, with our synergy company.
And that I think has also been, you know, as much
as mentoring people and helping them as, you know
giving it's also equally helping, you know
the person who is the mentor that I think has also
been helpful for me to be like,
okay, this is another thing that makes sense.
It makes sense for
what I just went through,
because then I'm able to
really shed light on this for someone who
I'm seeing this person go through
a very similar experience
that I went through on a different level
or in a different situation.
But, oh my gosh, like I know how to handle this
or I know how to give advice, or I know how to
Of course you do.
I mean, it's out of control, like, all right.
So with rise, which is this mentorship program
that you do you know that we've talked
about it with Caroline on the show.
I mean, imagine being a young athlete
and they're on the phone with you
or on a zoom call with you, it's like
I've set world records,
I've won, I've been to two Olympics
I've won medals, I've won, I've said American rock.
I've traveled all over the world.
I've done all of these things
and I've fallen on my face.
And I've been in situations
where the pressure was too overwhelming
and I've had breakdowns like that richness
of experience is so valuable
to any young person who's coming up.
And you see, they're gonna listen to you
who has more credibility
with any of this stuff than you.
It's really powerful.
Yeah, and it's one of those things that,
again, like but I have to be willing
to share those stories, right.
Like I have to be on op.
You have to be vulnerable.
Be vulnerable.
But that vulnerability is so much his strength.
That's your super power, right?
Like, like if you're
if you're LeBron or Michael,
like that's unrelatable.
Yes Michael's had his issues and you know, all of that
but somebody who has,
has blazed and impeccable career
that that looks unblemished
and that it's just this upwards,
you know, skyward trajectory.
It's very difficult to connect
with that person or to relate to them.
And when that person's like, well
you just got to gut it out.
You're like, well
you don't understand what I'm dealing with.
Yeah, it's not helpful.
You know what I mean?
Yeah and I think that
I actually have seen that wall break down
because even so right.
You're saying like,
okay, three time I look at metals
Olympian all these things.
And I think in the initial
But it's the failures that.
No, it is.
But I'm saying when you
when they initially hear that great.
But I don't think a lot of times,
you know, these some of them are younger.
Right, like they don't know like my full story
but I'll kind of seep it in
as we're getting to know each other
and talk and I'll be like, yeah.
So, you know, I work with a girl
who's just turned 16.
I'm like, yeah, I get it.
You're scared of this event.
I was scared of that event.
And then my nightmare was realized
when I literally threw up all over the deck
in front of millions of people
and I had to get back up and like
you can see like the, oh my gosh.
You know, like, I'm
I'm not sharing the highlight reel with you.
I'm sharing the full on behind the scenes.
And I, I can see the impact it makes up.
Oh, okay like we can relate to each other, you know.
And I, I think.
Or how about just like,
how do you get through puberty
when you have a male coach
who doesn't understand that, like,
there's so much to be learned and gleaned from,
from, you know the kind of experience that you can relate.
Yeah, and, and I think it's been
to have now the confidence
and the ability to,
to go there with the athletes,
you know Caroline has had brought Carolina
Rebecca have had rise for what
five years and right off the bat,
they were like, you know
do you wanna be a part of this?
I remember being like,
who would wanna listen to me?
Like, I need a mentor
like I'm flailing, you know, like, I
I didn't want to,
I thought I had had everything together
and I was all buttoned up and like,
I'm still not buttoned up you know.
Like I still have days where I struggle.
And now I just say that like, look, Hey
I'm telling you this,
I'm struggling with this right now.
Like, let's talk about this.
Like, it doesn't mean I have to be perfect.
And I think, I thought that that was what
had to happen in order for me
to be ready to be their mentor.
Right, right, right.
Yeah. I mean.
It feels so simple.
I know it's like, it's like
it's obvious and it's, it's self evident.
And yet I think
there's a lot of people for whom
that would be a revelation
for them to hear, you know
especially if you're
a young athlete coming up like, oh
you mean I can actually ask for help
or I don't have to be perfect all the time.
Well, it's kind of actually breaks my heart
even more to hear, because I was never someone who,
like I was the question asker.
I was, I was, at least you're willing to,
I wasn't afraid of a coach to be like,
I was that annoying person.
Like, wait, like, can you tell me more?
Like, how can I get better at this?
And yes, I didn't admit when I was struggling
as much but now days I feel like
kids are scared to even put themselves out there
to ask a question or ask for feedback.
And they're like, well, I asked.
Coach said this.
Yeah, and I'm like, wait, but why would you not?
The coach loves when you ask
how fast to go or they're like
yeah, but like, I don't want to look stupid
or I don't wanna,
I'm like, oh my gosh, like that's
I think that's really normal.
Like Todd had said to me,
I was like, can you believe that?
And he's like, yeah, that's,
it's pretty normal nowadays.
Like, people are scared of the rejection.
They're scared of again, the failure.
And that hits me even more because
I get what it was like to not admit,
you know, that I'm struggling,
but to take another step further,
that means that they can't admit
they're not struggling even more sell it.
They can't even ask for help.
Yeah, I wonder how much of that
is fueled by social media
where everybody's presenting these high gloss versions
of their lives and it makes a young person
feel even more inadequate than they already do
For sure I mean, I can't imagine
like I have TikTok and I see what's what's out there.
Yeah, and I can't like you see someone
and you're like, wait, that person's 16.
Like I know what I was doing
and what I was, you know
dancing like and all that when I was 16.
And it is eight.
After your first Olympics.
After my first Olympics.
(Katie and Rich laughing)
And this is a whole
this is a whole different different ball games.
So yeah, it's tough.
I think it's a lot harder.
And I think kids need that much more support and help.
And probably even more
than when I was coming up at that age.
Yeah well, we got around this down,
but I wanna I want to end with,
because most of the people watching
or listening to this
are probably more in the parental zone
than they are in the young athletes zone.
What kind of, you know, from glean,
from your experience like what are,
what's some wisdom that you could convey
to the parents out there to make sure
that they're kind of guiding their kids
whether their kids are athletes or just,
you know trying to learn how to grow up
in a high pressure environment.
What have you found to be helpful or not helpful?
I think a lot of times
when parents or coaches or mentors
sometimes they want to talk at the person
instead of just being a listening ear
and putting the athlete in a position to
feel comfortable to express.
I think we're all moving so fast.
We have cell phones all the time.
And so I think that a lot of times
kids probably don't feel comfortable.
They feel like their parents are too busy
or they're not going to share,
or the parents are just gonna supply.
It's okay you're okay right.
You know, had a parent text me the other day.
Athlete had a really tough meet and what should I say?
Like, don't say it's okay,
because that's, it just
tells the athlete how they're supposed to feel
like I used to hate it when people say that to me, like
it's not okay.
I just poured
Hours of blood, sweat, and tears into this.
Like, don't tell me how I'm supposed to feel.
You have the thing in the (indistinct).
The thing where when you go to the Olympics
and everybody tells you it's just another meet.
(Katie and Rich laughing)
I don't be like.
Okay like, I know that you're no,
it is not it is not.
That would drive me crazy.
So telling an athlete how they're supposed to feel.
And I think thing that my mom and dad did the best
of just being a listening ear, letting me vent
letting you get everything out
and then providing some perspective.
But non solicited advice happens way too much
in this universe, I think.
And that makes you wanna run the other direction
whether it's good or bad advice.
I think you're not going to take it in, in the right way.
And I try to do that when I'm I wanna hear it.
I just try to add, keep asking questions
keep asking questions
that aren't yes or no to them.
So that's, that's the biggest piece of advice.
So I won't ask you to give
a piece of unsolicited advice to Katie Ledecky.
Right now.
(Katie and Rich laughing)
I wouldn't like if she reached out and asked me great
But I, I think that's something
it's happened to me a lot in my life and my career.
And it's always been something where I'm like,
did I ask like I didn't ask, you know
and that's actually something I learned from Jack Roach.
He, I don't feel like you've talked about him.
Probably a ton of us.
You me he's like, come on the podcast,
but he was so good at just sitting down,
even if he was sitting in silence
because then it allowed me to
kind of pour my heart out if I wanted it to or not.
And then he would just listen, absorb.
And then, you know, if I asked he would give an opinion
but I think there has to be that relationship
of respect there of just feeling acknowledged.
Like just acknowledge me and how I'm feeling.
And then that advice can be given if asked for.
Yeah, for people listening or watching
or don't know who Jack Roach is.
Probably most people
he was the national junior team director for many years.
And, and, and, just beloved in the swimming community.
I have yet to meet a swimmer who, who
who wouldn't say that Jack is like their favorite person.
And I think a big part of that
is what you spoke about which is
this level of trust
that he engendered with the swimmers
and the level of respect that he gave to them.
Like they felt heard and listened to and appreciated.
So they feel safe going to him and,
and he was, you know protect he's protective
of those relationships.
Yeah and I think, and I think it's normal, right?
Like when, as I can't, I'm not a parent yet
but I can't imagine having a kid
and seeing their kid in so much pain.
Like, I don't know how my mom did it
watching what I went through with my dad.
But you instinctively wanna say,
well let me help you solve it.
Let's solve it.
And that's, that's the reaction.
You kind of have to fight that reaction
of like, okay but this person
maybe this person doesn't want what you're giving.
And I think this.
Right, it's about just sharing space.
But it's funny.
Cause you seem like somebody who'd be like
how do I solve this problem?
Like if, if somebody came to you and be like
I need to solve this problem for you.
Me.
like you're a problem solver
A hundred percent.
I have to fight that instinct all the time.
Like I just want to like
tell you what I think you should do
but then I'm like, no,
because that's what I've learned that I hate.
And I get so frustrated and
I think that's why sometimes
I would keep things in it's like
I don't even wanna put this out there
because I don't necessarily want you to solve it.
Or I don't feel like
you're the right person to solve it.
So yeah I, it's a, it's a something that
I know about myself.
And I dissected about myself that like
calm down, like don't solve this
keep asking questions and let them solve it.
Yeah what do you think is going to happen
with the Olympics this summer?
I hope it's just, I don't know.
It this past year broke my heart.
Can you imagine?
No.
What if it was you.
You know, coming, going into 08.
Going in 08.
It was, it was 2021 pandemic style.
I mean I feel like I would
Like how heartbreaking
I mean that's honestly, why.
Like when the pandemic started,
I thought, okay, what would what would I
it's right when I was kind of entering back
into the swimming world?
I'm like, well, what I want and that's why,
that's why we started synergy.
That's why I started doing these live workouts.
And I was like, sweating it out with the kids.
Cause I thought I would wanna
I wouldn't want someone to just be like,
stay positive control you can control.
I would want to say, yeah, but so what can I control
and what can I physically do
to say stronger outside the water.
And that's the thing I felt like, okay.
I think that's what I would do.
Like I would just, and I think that's what
all the you know, elite athletes
and people who are going
to see results this year have done.
Like they didn't just sit back and
show they were very upset
as I would have been
if they took things and thought,
okay look, let's get creative.
Let's build like these blow up pools.
Let's you know, like people had to get crazy
And just a diversity of experiences with respect
to pool access who could get into pools and who can't.
And I mean, it's crazy and how to
how to manage that like safely.
And it's so strange.
It's so strange.
And, and yeah, I just, I think again, like, right
like people who aren't necessarily
elite or haven't been in a situation like that,
they're like, yeah, but it's like
you know, it's like, no, the,
the Olympics is literally like everything I mean.
I think there's that study that.
And It's not like next time, like,
you know for some people it will play
to their benefit because
they were a little bit too young.
And so now they can grow into it.
Whereas others are, who are hanging on
Yeah, a year.
Like another year.
It's like in a ton of it.
Its like like yeah, forget it.
Yeah yeah, and I think.
Yeah, there's so many things.
Like it was a study where they asked someone
they asked like a group of athletes,
have you heard this where
if you could just maybe these Olympics
or if you could win an Olympic gold medal
but then die five years later, like guaranteed.
I think like it was staggering.
It was like 80% said, yes.
I heard that.
And where did I hear that too?
I did hear that recently.
Yeah It's shocking.
And I'm not that.
But it's the mentality
of somebody who's going to devote their life
to that goal is the person
who would make that statement.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, and I think I always bring that up
because I think that illustrates
that's how serious it is.
Like you are willing to like die
for like that goal.
And that's how much it means to you.
And I, it when you look at it,
you're like, that's ridiculous.
Like what I say that now.
But in that moment, when you're in that tunnel,
I probably would've said yes too.
You know and I think that that just
it's, it's the best best and worst part about it.
Yeah, ell, I think we did it.
How do you feel?
I loved it.
So when you're driving home after, or driving
wherever you're driving after this
I don't want you to like rehearsing this and things.
I totally, I will totally.
(Katie laughing)
I was gonna do everything.
Like I'm not I think it was a Nathan Adrian.
One time I, we were, we said something
And I was like, oh, like, I, for sure, like
I definitely like over analyze.
Everyone's like, why don't you just like go home
and just like, hang out with your friends.
It's like, I can't, I just always
I hate the people that are like
That are like, you, you, like
how does that person realize,
like how they're coming off?
You know, like those people.
And so I've always been like,
like, oh my God, like what if I
I'm not realizing how I'm coming off, you know.
I think you can put your mind at ease.
It was great.
You feel all right?
You feel good?
I feel great.
I appreciate that.
I was, I was really nervous.
I think we hit the the important things.
Yeah I really liked being able to just talk about,
it's almost like being able to share
my side of things
because for so long, I just really didn't get to.
And then just the piece about,
like you said, like I just love being able
to talk about, I hate talking about
like the world records,
like yeah that's great.
But like no one can relate to that.
They're like congrats you know,
failures to me is where
people can get it and feel.
That's the good stuff, you know.
Yeah, like they can feel like
they can learn from it or relate to it or, yeah.
I mean, I think, I think, I think what you've done
to date in your retirement is admirable and cool
but I think that there's a lot more awesome
cool stuff to come that I see you growing into.
Yeah, I'm really,
I'm really excited for the
I like the speaking stuff
as stuff that I'm most passionate about
because it's it texts, I'm not just a check the box
but it checks all the boxes in terms of like
you can share your story
which is cathartic for me still,
you can inspire people.
It's like our performance in some way,
like swimming was
you get adrenaline and all of that.
Like it's totally like that.
It's totally like that.
And then you can always get better.
You're never gonna, you're
just like I don't think you can ever have the perfect swim.
You're never gonna have the perfect speech.
There's always going to be ways to get better
and change it and tweak it.
And so I love that aspect of it too.
So I feel like that's kind of found my next endeavor.
Yeah, when the world opens up again.
I know I've done
I've done two virtual sales kicks off with a company
but it's like through a screen,
you know it's such a bummer but.
Yeah soon enough.
Soon enough.
Now, thank you so much for having me seriously.
Well, it's just super fun.
I loved it It was great really great.
And you're welcome back here any time.
Thank you.
Come back and visit me, okay.
Yeah.
Cool.
If you're digging on Katie, as I'm sure you are,
is it do you prefer Katie Anderson now?
Is that how, or is it Katie Hoff or Katie Hoff Anderson?
Like how do you go?
What's the
(Katie and Rich laughing)
I legally
I think people know you as Katie Hoff from swim
But now you're, you're married and.
I'm Katie Anderson.
I'm Katie Anderson legally
but I'm Katie Hoff.
Like if I'm doing like
You're at Katie Hoff seven is who you are.
You know why the seven is there.
Why, seven gold medals.
No.
(Katie and Rich laughing)
That was like off.
The seven gold medals that you didn't win.
The seven gold medals that I didn't win, no.
Lane seven and the 400 IM
and 04 was when we met first one team.
Oh, that's cool I like that story.
Yeah so yeah.
Katie Hoff, Katie and I, yeah.
I always go with K T
Yeah K T.
Because everyone always calls me KT.
Also someone stole my handle.
Really just K A T I E Hoff at Katie Hoff.
Katie Hoff or for the, for a website.
katiehoff.com was bought the day
after I made the Olympic team in 04.
No way.
By like IPG.
Well, there's like squatting laws now.
People aren't allowed to do that.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Yeah they said they were good.
Like it was gonna be like 10 K for me to buy it.
And I was like, I'll just go by Katie, Katie Hoff.
Yeah, all right.
Well, that's good.
We all know you that there are now.
And the book is blueprint
and synergy is the online dry land program.
Yeah, it's we work with teams.
We work with individuals.
It's, it's been my entrepreneurship realized
with my husband which has been kind of a cool
he's the brains behind it.
And I'm the swimming lens and
yeah, we do everything.
He actually just did a virtual,
a virtual session of your talking.
Oh, wow cool we didn't even get into
what it's like to work with your husband.
We could have a whole two-hour podcast about that.
So we'll do that next time.
All right, cool.
Enjoy the rest of your time in LA
and so nice to meet you and talk to you.
Yes, thank you so much.
Peace.
Bye.